Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking it now as a
like
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
This episode is brought to you by four sigmatic.
You might remember four sigmatic mushroom coffee,
which was created by those clever finished founders and when I first mentioned
that coffee on this podcast,
the product sold out in less than a week at lights you up like a Christmas tree,
which can be really useful.
However,
recently I've been testing the opposite side of the spectrum and new product and
that is their Reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my day to get to sleep.
As you guys may know,
longtime listeners,
at least I struggled with insomnia for decades.
I have a largely fixed that,
but still shutting off my monkey brain has never been easy,
still isn't easy very often and I found Reishi,
which I've been fascinated by for a few years now,
has been very,
very effective and calming their old formula.
However,
forcing Maddix old formula included Stevia and I like to avoid sweeteners,
all sweeteners for a host of reasons,
and I then just ping them and asked,
hey guys,
I would love to experiment with this and maybe actually suggested,
but I'd like a version without sweeteners if you'd be open to it,
if too much of a headache,
don't worry.
And they are always game for experimentation.
So they created a special custom version without the Stevia,
without sweeteners.
Now it is part of my nightly routine.
Their ratio looks or comes in single serving packets,
which are perfect for travel.
And in fact,
I'm about to leave the country right now and I have a packet in front of me
that's just going to sit in the end of my carry on bag.
You only need hot water and it mixes very,
very easily.
Here's some recommended copy that they put in the read,
so I'm going to read it and then I'll give you my take quote,
a warning.
For those in the experimental mindset,
Reishi is strong and bitter in parentheses like any great medicine.
So if the bitterness is too much,
I recommend trying it with honey end or nut milk such as almond milk and quote,
so I'm going to say no,
you should suck it up and you should drink the tea because it's not that bitter
and maybe should take the advice of all Chinese people when they're criticizing
younguns.
When they say Boone,
I'm sure cool.
Which means you're not able to eat bitterness.
Bitter is in many cases and indication of things that help liver detoxification
and so on.
Not saying that's the case here,
but I've tested this ratio lecture on family members,
on friends.
Everybody has liked it.
It's a little bit earthy.
It's not that hard,
so I would just say suck it up and no,
don't put in honey or milk or any of that shit.
Just drink the goddamn tea.
It's delicious,
I think.
Right?
If you like poo air,
that kind of stuff,
that type of tea,
you're going to dig it,
so just try it.
Okay.
Back to then my read.
If you'd like to naturally improve your sleep,
both onset and quality,
I think naturally you might just enjoy this ratio elixir without any sweeteners.
It has organic,
Reishi extract,
organic fueled to mint extract,
organic rose hips extract,
organic Tulsi extract,
and that's it.
No fancy stuff,
no artificial watching McCall at anything.
So check it out.
Go to foursigmatic.com forward slash and Ferris and get 20% off this special
batch.
I don't know if they're gonna be making much more of this,
uh,
since it was made specifically for you guys to do me a favor and try it out so
that they continue to be open to experimenting with me to create products for
you guys.
Specifically,
check it out.
Four sigmatic,
that's Fou,
a t,
I c.com forward slash Ferris,
F,
e R,
r,
I s,
s and get 20% off the special batch.
And you must use the code Ferris to receive a discount.
F,
e,
R,
r,
I s.
S.
So again,
go to foursigmatic.com forward slash Ferris and then use code Ferris for 20% off
of this rare,
exclusive,
limited run of Reishi mushroom elixir for nighttime routines with out any
sweeteners.
Enjoy.
This episode is brought to you by we work.
I love,
we work.
I haven't had an office in many,
many,
many years since 2000 or so when I had my last real job I suppose and quotation
marks,
but when I moved from San Francisco to Austin,
not long guy decided,
you know what,
I'm tired of working at home.
I'm tired or we're going to coffee shops.
So one of the very first things I did was to get a space at we work.
I could not be happier with this change in my life.
We work is a global network of workspaces where companies and people grow
together.
The idea is really simple.
You focus on your business and we work,
takes care of all of the rest,
including front desk service,
utilities,
refreshments and more.
I also often have things shipped from Amazon and elsewhere to my office that we
work here in Austin.
I've been completely blown away by the members only events,
special offers,
and perhaps the best cold brew coffee on tap that I've ever had.
It's been amazing.
It's been a real,
real change in my life and improve my quality of life and there are also dog
friendly.
We work locations all over the place.
How Fun is that?
We work caters to everyone from entrepreneurs and freelancers to start ups and
even large enterprises including Ge,
salesforce,
Microsoft,
mastercard,
Samsung,
Spotify,
Pinterest,
and red bull among many others.
In fact,
more than 10% of fortune 500 companies currently use.
We work and it's a rapidly growing group.
In other words,
it's not just solar printers and to ground level startups that use we work,
but everything from that to the big companies who are seeing very huge benefits
as well.
We work believes that creating spaces where people can connect and create
meaning together,
right?
And after all,
if you are someone who has built a business modeled on the principles and the
four hour workweek or elsewhere,
it can be a lonely road.
Sometimes even though you're digitally connected,
it can feel very,
very isolating.
So in these spaces you can connect with real humans and uh,
all the while you space more efficiently and cost effectively,
which makes you and your business better equipped to face the challenges of
today and tomorrow.
We work now has more than 200 locations,
so you can find great spots all over the world.
So head over to [inaudible] dot co slash Tim that's [inaudible] Dot Cosio so
we'd got co Ford Slash Tim to become a part of the global we were community.
At the very least.
I encourage you to check out pictures of some of the locations around the world.
There are some incredible spots.
So check it out.
[inaudible] dot co forward slash Tim
low boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
My guest today is Daniel Pink.
Daniel pink on Twitter.
He is the author of six provocative books,
including his newest when subtitle,
the scientific secrets of perfect timing.
When is a New York Times Wall Street Journal USA Today,
Washington Post and publisher's weekly bestseller.
That's a lot of lists.
Pinks,
other books include the long running New York Times bestseller,
a whole new mind,
and the Number One New York Times best sellers drive and to sell is human.
His books have won multiple awards and had been translated into 37 languages at
last count.
He lives in Washington DC with his family.
You can also find his work,
his various goings on@danpink.com and if Facebook is your thing,
facebook.com forward slash Daniel h pink.
Dan,
welcome to the show.
Tim,
thanks for having me.
It has been quite awhile since we allow years,
several years.
And uh,
I know we were talking about all things Japanese most likely,
uh,
at least in,
in one of our recent conversations based on one of your books.
Uh,
and maybe you could tell people actually just as context a little bit about that
book that we were chatting about in Monga format or Japanese comic format.
And we'll use that as a jumping off point.
Yes,
indeed.
That was one of my best ideas.
That didn't go anywhere.
MMM.
Um,
so I,
that was a book called the adventures of Johnny Bunko.
And,
and as you say,
Tim,
it was written in the Japanese comic format known as Monga.
And as you know,
as a Japan of file in Japan,
Mongo,
the comic format is,
is much more versatile and more widely used than it is here in the United
States.
So,
uh,
so you grown ups who reading comics,
and it can be things about financial advice,
things about love,
life,
things about history.
And so I did a fellowship in Japan with my wife and our three kids where I
studied the Monga industry and I came back and said,
you know what?
I think it's time for Monga to broaden its reach here in the United States of
America.
So I wrote a book called the adventures of Johnny Bunko and it's a,
uh,
graphic novel in a Manga form,
that reveals the six essential lessons of any satisfying,
productive career through the story of a hapless young accountant named Johnny
Bunko.
That was a fantastically concise description.
And I wanted to also,
you said in the beginning that it was the best idea that didn't go anywhere or
something along those lines.
And I wanted to bring up the book because it seems for those people,
it struck a chord with it struck very deep cord and I believe it was Kevin
Kelly,
arguably the most interesting man in the world who was on this yet.
And he mentioned that that book was at least at the time,
his most gifted book.
So I wanted to at least highlight the fact that if it's good enough for Kevin
Kelly,
it should be good enough for many,
many other people.
That's like,
that's exactly right.
Oh,
Kevin has.
Kevin did say that and I actually think it's a good book.
We did reasonably well with it.
It didn't blow off the doors.
I think I was,
you know,
and this is a,
this is a common,
uh,
thing that happens in,
in,
in life and an investing in entrepreneurship and publishing and anything is that
you can be right too early.
I think that's what it was.
That that I actually think that this format of graphic novels and comics having
a more expansive region,
the United States is probably going to happen.
Uh,
I might've been as they would say in my,
in,
in the world of politics,
I might've been a little ahead of the voters
or using a surfing metaphor,
paddling a little too early for the wave,
which take thing,
which sometimes means you don't catch a wave and investing at sometimes mean
you'd paddle right into the impact zone and then get smashed that you mentioned,
you mentioned politics.
I wasn't going to go here right away.
Oh boy.
But,
and I'm going to get there in two hops,
but so I'm looking at in front of me the Yale Law and policy review volume eight
number two 1990 and it says it like top,
this is like a,
it's like a deposition exhibit a
30 years ago that you're going to make me pay for.
Right now
I'm auditioning indirectly I'll be at for my role on true TV as tell dad.
But this won't go into any incriminating territory unless you volunteer or
something along those lines.
Which I,
which I doubt will happen,
but it says on top of the editor and chief Daniel h pink.
So how did fate intervene that you are not currently in the legal profession?
Oh my God,
this is the one area where I want to thank for or her grace and kindness.
Um,
here's the thing.
I,
I went to law school and I went to law school largely because I was a middle
class kid from the middle of America and that's kind of what you did.
And once I started saw the inside and it was a terrible decision and it actually
helped me figure out how to make better decisions.
Um,
it gave me some were actually really good advice on how to make better
decisions.
But I basically went to law school without knowing what lawyers did or even what
law school was.
It was just something I did because that's what I was supposed to do.
I found out I didn't really like it very much.
And I,
and once I found out what lawyers actually did,
and God bless the lawyers listening to this,
but once I found out what lawyers actually did,
I was like,
Oh,
you,
you hire somebody else to do that.
You know,
it's like,
like,
you know,
it's like,
I mean,
it takes like,
it takes skill to like plunge a toilet or you know,
you know,
that kind of thing.
Um,
or you know,
uh,
mow a gigantic backyard.
I mean,
it takes skill to do that.
It's just that,
you know what,
it's really not my thing.
And so what I'd rather do is do something else and then pay someone else to do
that kind of dirty work.
Um,
and yet I found myself stuck and because I was risk averse that I did leave for
a little while.
Actually I dropped out for a little while,
but I came back.
Um,
and um,
and so I went to la,
so I went to law school.
It wasn't a,
you know,
Greg accumulated massive,
massive,
massive student loans.
But I was very fortunate in two dimensions in my law school trajectory.
One was that my school had a ve,
a very pro,
uh,
ahead of its time loan payback program,
t to salary.
So if you made less than a certain amount,
they would offer assistance in repaying your student loans.
And that gave people much more,
nobody,
not many people took it,
but that gave you theoretically more career flexibility if you decided not to
practice law.
The other thing is that I met my wife in law school,
so it's,
it's,
um,
it's a decision that ended up having a profound positive effect on my life.
How does it help you learn to make better decisions?
The law going to law school,
he said,
well,
here's the thing.
Okay.
You know,
here's what I did.
Here's what I did.
And here's the thing.
I,
okay,
so there's this principle in social science.
It has a fancy name,
but it is something that we all do and it's something that we should do is a
principle of surrogation.
Okay.
How do you make decisions?
You use the principle of surrogation and surrogation basically means find
someone like you who made this decision and see what happened to him or her.
That is,
find out what it's really like.
It's a,
again,
this is a totally fancified way of something that is very common sensical Wa,
you know,
should I go to this restaurant?
Well let me check the Yelp reviews up.
47 other people who've gone through this restaurant and what I did.
And it's amazing to me,
Tim,
when I think about this and it's advice that I give to my own kids as well.
I went to law school,
literally having never spent a day,
but not a day,
10 minutes talking to him lawyer.
But that's absolutely the case.
I went to law school having never sat in on a law school class.
I mean,
it's unbelievable to me in retrospect.
And,
and so had I done those kinds of things,
I might have approached it more skeptically.
Um,
but I didn't do those things.
And so,
uh,
and,
and because that ended up being an incredibly expensive decision,
even though it led to some pot,
you know,
it basically,
I mean,
it led to the most positive thing in my life,
which is my wife,
even though it led to something positive,
it was a terrible decision.
So now I'm Ma,
I'm sort of a,
um,
uh,
a surrogation,
idealogue,
you know,
it's like I believe in segregation for everything.
Um,
largely because I got bitten by that bad decision.
Could you give us an example of at some fork in the road or some perspective
decision where you've used surrogation or where you're planning on using it?
Okay.
So I'll give you an example of it.
So,
um,
yeah,
it's,
you know,
again,
we're not talking rocket science here.
We're talking to like basically,
hey,
act like a reasonably intelligent grownup is,
it is what it is,
you know,
is basically what I'm when I'm doing here.
But let's go back to the,
let's go back to the Japan.
Uh,
I think I saw,
I got a fellowship to go to Japan and I went with my wife and our,
and our kids as I mentioned.
But before I did that,
I talked to six different people who had the same fellowship before I accepted
six different people who had the same fellowship,
what it was like for their kids,
what would,
what the work was like,
what the living was like before I made the decision.
Now again,
that is not a monumental intellectual breakthrough,
but it's something that I didn't do when I was much younger.
Well,
it's,
it's a best practice that can often get skipped,
right?
Whether that's something like this or something,
it should be very straight forward.
If you look at say a tool,
go on days work and the checklist manifesto in checking various things to avoid
bacteria line infections in the hospital,
right?
It's very straightforward,
but if you neglect it over time,
bad things are gonna happen.
But it's also the,
you know,
I think that as,
as I've gotten older and gotten more experience,
I've actually,
um,
become much more aware of the importance of intellectual humility.
And like what,
you know,
not always.
When I think of when I was younger,
I felt,
well I,
I know what it law schools like how do you know?
I just know because I thought about it once.
And so I know,
uh,
I know what lawyers do because like I met somebody who was a lawyer and I know
what lawyers,
you know,
and so there's a degree of arrogance in that I'm thinking that you know
something when you actually don't.
And so if you approach all kinds of decisions with a degree of intellectual
humility and ask yourself,
what don't I know about this,
where am I blind spots?
And then I think you end up making better decisions.
Definitely.
Speaking of blind spots,
I promised I would segue into politics and that is somewhere,
uh,
I have very,
very little confidence in any of my knowledge or expertise.
How did you,
so it was looking at what I believe to be one of your first articles that
really,
I'm not going to say put you on the map.
That's too,
too much of an overstatement.
But the,
the free agent nation article in Fast Company,
which was at the end of 1990.
Yeah,
1997.
And in the bio or the byline rather of that article it says until recently,
chief speech writer to Vice President Al Gore.
So where did you go from law school or dropping out of law school for a period
of time to speech writing for then Vice President Al Gore?
Well,
when I graduated from law school,
I was actually very keenly interested in politics.
It was probably my deepest interest at the time.
And I said,
you know what,
I'm going to go where I'm going to work in politics.
Why was it interesting to you at the time?
Uh,
but a couple of reasons.
Number one is that I thought it'd be,
it was a venue for,
for achieving something in the world and make a contribution to the world.
The other thing is that I found the actual practice of it quite exciting and
interesting and the way that sports is exciting and interesting.
So it was a combo platter for me.
Um,
and,
uh,
and I'd been interested in it for many,
many years and I said,
okay,
this is,
this is what I,
this is what I want to do.
So I got out of law school and I started working on political campaigns,
which at the time I liked because political campaigns are totally interesting.
I mean,
again,
it's like a sport in that there's,
you know,
there's a beginning and there's an end and there is a clear,
clear outcome.
Uh,
and it's exciting and you're making decisions on the fly.
And I find political campaigns more than other kinds of organizations and
institutions fairly meritocratic because there's so much going on.
It's so much crazy stuff happening that if you can do something,
you will continue,
you'll,
you'll be asked to do it again.
And that's pretty much what happened to me.
And that someone at some point asked me to write a speech and I did it and it
was okay.
And then they said,
hey,
that's okay.
You want to do it again?
And I did it again.
And then I did it a third time and all of a sudden that was my job.
Um,
and,
and um,
and it ended up being something that I,
I had a certain affinity for.
And um,
and it's something that a lot of other people did not.
And so just in the supply and demand of who has to do what,
that's what I ended up doing.
And I,
and I enjoyed it.
I did it on political campaigns.
I did it for a cabinet secretary and then I ended up doing it for the,
I ended up doing it for the vice president.
And the trouble was is that when I had spent all these years in the belly of the
beast,
you know,
it's sort of like,
wow,
I really want to work in politics.
And all of a sudden and a pretty kind of half ass way.
I was at a pretty good gig in the belly of the beast.
Um,
I realized,
Hey,
I'm not sure this is my thing.
I thought this is my thing,
but I'm discovering that this is not my thing.
And it was even is that if I project out even further,
um,
and look at,
say what I'm going to be like or what I'm going to be doing in 10 years or 20
years,
I really don't like that picture cause I see some of those people around me.
Hmm.
Is there anything besides the projecting forward,
looking at the people who had been in the game,
so to speak for a longer period of time and saying,
wow,
I could see myself filling their shoes and I don't like what that looks like.
Was there anything else,
any other indicators or moments that made you realize it wasn't for you?
There were a few things.
Um,
first of all,
the amount of bs that was involved was startling to me.
I expected some,
but the,
if you do,
if you do a pie chart of bs and not be as the BS slice coordinate,
it's extraordinarily large,
larger than larger than you would larger than you would imagine.
I'm on a number of different dimensions.
And here's the thing,
Tim,
I fricking lucked out to and who I was working for because my last two jobs I
worked for Al Gore,
who was a very smart guy and a very good guy all around.
And the guy before that I worked for the then Labor secretary was a speech
writer for the then Labor Secretary,
a guy named Robert Reisch who's a very smart guy and a good guy.
And so I had basically the best kinds of bosses you could possibly have.
Um,
and so that was another indication,
like I got the best bosses that you could possibly have.
And I still like,
hmm,
it's not the species of rice or Gore.
I don't like,
it's the genus of politics that is actually bringing me down,
you know?
And so,
uh,
and so among the things that I did in like,
let's go back to the BS,
uh,
there was an enormous amount of enormous amount of time spent basically,
um,
in the air,
in almost everything that was going on within the boundaries of the law is
concerned for basically pandering and fundraising.
Um,
it was really quite remarkable.
The other thing is that I also felt like I let a lot of the people who are good
people,
that they were so interested and they were so absorbed in the mechanics of
things that they,
I felt like I was losing sight over like what we were doing here in the first
place.
What did we actually,
what do we actually believe in that the,
uh,
and there was so much short term ism,
so much short term,
insane kind of posturing and,
and Ooh,
let's get this slight advantage over the day.
Um,
and um,
and it was like,
what's the point?
What's the point of all this?
I'm working really,
really hard and I'm not sure this is,
I'm not sure we're actually doing that much.
And here's the scary part is like,
that was 20 years ago.
In retrospect,
those were the good old days,
right?
I mean,
you,
you have,
I mean,
you,
you know,
we were,
I mean,
I'm old enough.
I did as long enough ago where I'd be,
I'd be pumped when something I wrote made it onto the quote unquote evening
news.
I haven't watched the evening news for 19 years,
you know,
um,
uh,
we weren't dealing with social media.
The world was very,
very,
very partisan then,
but nothing like the way it is now.
So I remember devoting a couple of days in my office to some subpoena that was
given to Gore's office for finding some document about some nonsense thing and
I'm like,
and I,
and I'm like really concerned about that because I didn't do anything wrong,
but it's like,
oh my God,
if I have an email that mentioned x,
y,
orZ and I don't find it,
and then someone else finds it,
like I'm going to have to hire a lawyer and I didn't sign up for this garbage.
So,
um,
so I finally decided to,
I finally,
yeah.
So,
so again,
this thing that I thought I was deeply,
deeply interested in,
once I actually experienced it,
I found myself far less interested in it then.
Then I would have suspected,
if you had told me that when I left that job,
if you had told me 10 years earlier,
you're going to have this job and you're going to leave it because you're,
you're tired of politics,
I would have been very,
very surprised.
Okay.
If you look back at that experience,
the skills you either had natively or developed,
uh,
okay.
How do you prepare your speeches now or,
or maybe if we take an example of a speech that you've given that has received
very positive feedback or really from your perspective,
engage the audience.
How do you prepare?
How do you go about preparing a 30 minute,
60 minute speech?
What does,
what does that look like?
Is there any example that you can give us?
Yeah,
I mean it,
it,
it depends.
I mean actually that experience writing speeches was actually extraordinarily
useful in going out and,
you know,
being a writer and then going out and talking about what I've written about.
I mean,
it's extraordinarily useful.
I mean if,
if for one,
if for no other reason,
Tim,
it was because,
you know,
I spent a lot of time as a speech writer,
um,
watching audiences react,
seeing what worked and what,
seeing what worked and what did it,
and that I think has that completely,
uh,
left an imprint on me.
Um,
again,
I was able to,
uh,
you know,
I had this before I went out on doing it myself.
I spent as much time as any human being could have done,
like watching speeches being given,
but I always would watch whenever,
when any of my bosses would give a speech.
I would actually watch the audience rather than my boss,
um,
to see,
because that's how I learned how to get better at it.
Hey,
that line works.
that line's a dud.
Hey,
they're spacing out here.
this,
this person over here looks confused.
Um,
wow.
This went on too long.
Wow.
This could have gone on a little blue.
I've never had to experience that.
Could've gone on longer,
but
seriously,
this could,
we could,
we could have,
we could have cut it out there.
Um,
and so,
um,
so seeing audiences react just gave me a,
I mean it's hard to,
it's almost like,
um,
we think of an analogy here.
Um,
okay.
I mean this is an imperfect analogy,
but it's almost like,
um,
I'm going to go,
basically walk up and down the streets of Santiago,
Chile for a couple of years.
I'm not going to do any talking,
but I'm going to listen to everybody else talking and it's like,
Whoa,
you can learn some Spanish that way.
It's not going to be,
you're not going to be perfectly Spanish,
but you have a huge advantage of someone if you do that and then go and say,
Hey,
I'm think I'm going to learn how to speak Spanish.
It also makes me think of a,
a,
a very useful feature for potential speakers,
although it's probably not worth the Labor for the Ted Organization would be to
take the camera.
See,
that's always pointed at the audience and give you the option of,
of listening to Ted talks while watching the audience respond.
That's an interesting idea.
I mean,
they,
they do cutaways on those kinds of things,
but the cutaways don't show people being bored.
Right.
When exactly.
That's actually,
that's actually more revealing than any than,
than anything else.
And I'll tell you like from the speech of givers point of view,
and it's interesting you raise this Tim,
because I haven't really thought a huge amount about it myself,
but one of the things that I enjoy most about giving talks is seeing the
audience's reaction,
um,
and figuring out what's good and what isn't.
So if I come up with a,
hey,
I got this killer line,
I just thought of this is going to totally rule and then I deliver it and it's
like,
Whoa,
that bombed.
Um,
and in my head I don't feel like,
oh,
I'm so sad that it bombed.
But in the back of my head I'm like,
ha,
that bomb.
That's so interesting.
I got to make a note of that.
Like that one bomb,
you know?
Um,
and why is,
why did that one bomb?
Do people not understand it?
Was it,
was it obnoxious?
Um,
and so I love that part of it.
When you give speeches,
when you do something in real time with people,
there it really anything before an audience.
So if you and I were talking before a live audience,
we would be getting feedback on our conversation that I,
that I think would be really useful and interesting.
And when you do things that are asynchronous as we're doing now,
we're writing a book which is asynchronous.
You get that feedback much later.
And so the feedback is less is less meaningful.
So if I,
um,
uh,
if I write something and someone says,
you wrote this passage here,
I just don't get it.
Um,
that's sort of a bummer for me because I don't have time to cure it.
But if I say something before an audience and I get a bunch of blank looks,
I immediately know.
Wow,
okay.
I didn't explain that very well.
I got to go back next time around and get explained it better.
So I've,
so many different questions I want to dig into related to what you just said.
Uh,
first is
actually connected to something we were talking about just before we hit record.
And that was,
uh,
you having listened to the interview I did with Brian Compliment the screen
writer,
a filmmaker,
a cocreator of the,
the hit show billions among many other things and his pension to end
recommendation for forensically studying film,
watching films with a notebook in hand and taking notes on what worked,
what didn't his responses and so on.
And you,
you mentioned a number of different questions and cues that you might ask
yourself while watching in your speech writer days,
the audience,
while you're this sensibly,
your boss is giving a talk.
Would you be writing those things down?
Uh,
would it be,
would you be sitting there kind of with a,
uh,
a notebook in hand recording this,
this type of thing?
Um,
what I would be,
uh,
what I would often be doing would be,
um,
I would have,
okay,
so if I had a,
it was a speech where it had a written where there was a written text,
which is not always the case in some cases for for lower key,
for less significant things.
It would be say,
you know,
conversation and some talking points and some things like that,
but let's say for a speech that was actually delivered,
that is a speech that was written out and then delivered,
um,
you know,
behind a podium.
I would almost always have the actual physical text of the speech and I would
mark up that physical text of it.
So,
so,
and in some cases,
because it was helpful for me in terms of just relating to my own boss,
let's say that he skipped a paragraph.
I like,
hmm,
I wonder why I skipped that paragraph.
You know,
maybe ask him about that or maybe I could even figure out why you skipped that.
he skipped,
he didn't even bother reading a paragraph where we skipped a line or he ad
libbed a do a new version of the line.
That was actually very helpful to me in terms of just dealing with my boss.
Because again,
what you're trying to do,
and it's in writing a speech for somebody else,
is that you're,
you're trying to make that person sound like the best version of him or herself.
And so it could be that the way I phrased something didn't sound like him,
but he knew what I meant.
And he was able to phrase it in his own words.
And that actually was helpful for me in terms of doing the,
the,
the tactical craft of my job.
Um,
but so I would have,
I would have the text with me,
let's say there was a joke,
you know,
I would say I'm at a,
basically it would like,
plus I'm serious,
like plus and minus,
you know,
um,
and say,
hey,
that joke worked.
That joke didn't work,
that line of work,
that,
that line,
that line didn't work.
Um,
and one of the things that it taught me was also is that you don't go based on,
uh,
I'm,
I'm getting in the weeds here a little bit,
but you don't make permanent decisions based on one reaction.
And I do that myself now in my own stuff.
So if I say something and it doesn't work the first,
I don't say I don't abandon it,
then I make a note of that and then I try it again because sometimes different
audiences,
different contexts,
different things,
it can work.
But,
um,
so,
but,
but I,
yeah,
I would do that.
It was just sort of,
you know,
here's the thing.
I don't want to make this sound like,
like,
or use the word forensic that talk about what compliment is doing.
Mine was less forensic,
it was more um,
hygienic.
It was to me it's like that's just like good staff hygiene,
you know?
I,
you know what I mean?
I wrote a speech and this dude is delivering it.
I should pay attention to like how it's going,
you know?
And if I do that,
if I do that,
I'm going to do better next time and he's going to do better.
Exxon,
if I look at the my own writing,
the writing that I've done that has,
has received the best response it,
we'll just keep it broad.
Nine Times out of 10,
it's something that I have tested and honed in some speaking format,
whether it's a presentation or a class or something else,
which is part of the reason why if,
if I'm giving a talk or doing an interview in front of a live audience,
I always ask them to raise the house lights because for whatever reason,
a lot of venues like,
sure,
really dumb it down,
but then you can't see the response.
So I always had a way to raise the house lights.
When you are testing out a speech or an article or a chapter on someone else,
uh,
what types of questions,
what are you looking for or what types of questions do you ask?
You can pick any of those that you'd like,
but,
but what type of question guys do you ask?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Let me take your simple question.
A complicated,
let's go.
Because I actually think that that speeches and written words are different
things.
Okay.
Um,
and so,
uh,
so the way that I would convey an idea in a speech is going to be different from
the way that I would convey the similar same idea in a book.
Um,
and so,
um,
so,
so for me,
um,
like one of the most important,
like I,
I'd say it's a,
it's a simple question,
but,
uh,
and I,
I find myself asking it all the time to people is this following question.
Does that make sense?
Um,
or what I've sometimes found a easier way to rephrase that is this is actually,
I think it's actually useful,
uh,
uh Ha,
writing I guess.
What about that doesn't make sense.
Yeah.
I think that people,
I think that people are more likely to say,
does that make sense there?
You know,
it's sort of out of politeness and also just out of self.
Oh,
of course.
That makes sense.
Oh yeah.
You know,
but sort of what about that?
So I converted a little bit.
What about that?
What about that doesn't make sense with when you give us,
when you,
when you explain an idea to somebody or you're talking to an audience,
I really think,
I mean,
maybe I'm overestimating my own abilities,
but I really think you can tell by the look on people's
faces.
Um,
there are all other kinds of markers of that too.
So for instance,
um,
you know,
especially now if you have slides,
what are people taking pictures of?
All right,
what slides are they taking pictures of?
What things are they writing down?
Um,
so I look at those kinds of cues in,
in,
in talks.
I think writing is more difficult.
And I'll tell you what I do in,
in writing,
especially books.
And this is a little bit insane.
Uh,
or it's,
it's,
I mean,
it's insane in the sense that you were,
it requires,
it requires someone who is deeply devoted to you in a way that someone you truly
love is devoted to you.
So here's the,
here's the thing about my books.
Um,
I,
even though I'm,
even though I just said speeches and written words are different for me,
I actually improved my writing by listening to it.
Not because I listened to written words different from the way I listened to
speeches,
if that makes any sense.
And so when I write books,
so the latest book,
I mean,
you know,
latest book and all the previous books,
um,
I,
I have an office here behind my house in Washington DC.
It's a garage refurbish garage and four,
I will sit in my office and I'll give it,
let's talk about the latest book.
Okay.
Just to give you an idea.
So this is a book,
I don't know,
it's like 280 pages,
something like that.
Um,
I read every word of that book out loud to my wife at various stages.
What's,
what's more,
I read drafts,
multiple drafts of chapters out loud to my wife in this office.
But wait,
there's more.
My,
my wife read every word of this book out loud to me,
including drafts because for me,
that's how I,
that's how I processed the,
that's how I processed the written word.
So for me,
I can tell what works in a speech because you have a large audience of people
behind,
you know,
reacting to it went in terms of written words like I,
I don't know,
it's just like I,
you know,
after all these years I know what's good and what's not when it comes to the
written word.
And I actually know what's not good really is what I know.
And so I tried to remove all the not good stuff.
Um,
and uh,
and the way I do that and is a very laborious way is to read aloud because that
helps me look at the words a different way,
but also to have them read aloud to me.
Now what's amazing to this and shows you just how incredible and awesome my wife
is,
is that I am the worst person on the planet to be read aloud too,
because I'm a complete pain in the ass when it comes to,
especially if you're reading my,
my words.
Oh,
come on.
You got to read with more expression than that.
Oh,
come on.
No,
the emphasis is on that word.
No.
MMM.
My safely might.
Saintly wife has done this for several,
several,
several books now.
Wow.
She's a keeper.
Uh,
I,
I've only,
I suspect this is more common than either of us might expect,
but,
uh,
John McPhee,
the nonfiction writer also writes,
I think he still writes for the New Yorker.
Fascinating guy.
But I took a seminar with him in Undergrad and he also explained how he reads
all of his word.
I believe he reads not only his feature works,
but his articles out loud to his wife.
Really?
I actually did not know that.
Yup.
So this is,
yeah.
Well,
I'm pretty good.
I'm in,
I'm in pretty good company.
I started reading,
I started reading John Mcphee when I was like a,
like a pretty,
you know,
like a young teenager and one of the best McPhee books I've read was a book you
might've read it called levels of the,
it's so good.
I get so,
so good.
Maybe you can just love that book.
I read it
again.
I actually read it again,
uh,
about two years ago,
but I read it,
I read it as a kid.
Um,
you know I got it out of the library.
I spent a lot of time in libraries when I was a kid and I don't know how some
librarian or somebody told me about it cause there was a,
because he has that famous book about Bill Bradley,
a sense of where you are.
So I read that because I was a basketball fan and it's like,
oh,
I was also a tennis fan.
It's like,
oh you read about tennis too.
And I read that book and I,
you know,
it's time.
I guess I was,
I was saying,
wow,
you can actually write about sports in a way that's kind of more interesting
than just sports.
Um,
that's a remarkable book.
I mean,
I can explain it quick.
So it's a,
it's a story about a match between a single tennis match between Arthur Ashe,
uh,
who would then was very young just out of Richmond and a guy named Clark
Grabner,
who was from a,
a wealthier white guy,
wealthier family in I think it was like suburban Cleveland.
And what he does is he basically describes the match,
but throughout he pulls back and tells each of their stories of how they
actually got to the court that day.
I think it was the u s open a US Open match.
And so he actually describes them playing a point and then he pulls back and
talks about how Arthur ash got there and he pulls back and talks about how Clark
Grabner got there.
And he does it with such elegance in such concision.
It's just the,
that's,
uh,
it's a joy to behold.
It's,
it's truly spectacular.
And for those who haven't read Mixi,
you should,
if not for any other reason that he can take any subject matter you can imagine,
uh,
and make a riveting book about said subject.
It could be oranges,
Plymouth Rock,
uh,
origins book look as great.
I read that one.
I was a kid to carve,
carve canoes,
geology.
It just,
you name the topic and he can turn it into a page Turner.
But levels,
levels of the game is,
is just spectacular.
And one,
one thing that mixed fee is very,
very good at is,
and I think this is also shared territory with you,
is asking questions.
It given the nature of his writing,
uh,
a very significant portion of his time is spent interviewing.
And what about that doesn't make sense is a really powerful tweak on the maybe
alternative that you mentioned,
which is does this make sense?
Right.
What does this make sense or not?
And I,
I this,
this may be digging too far into the weeds,
but I was really fascinated to read about an approach that you've detailed in
one of your books called motivational interviewing.
And I,
and I hadn't heard of this before,
uh,
but the,
the example that stuck out to me,
and you don't have to give this exact example,
but was,
uh,
asking a student who is seemingly struggling with Algebra,
a a certain question and instead of others,
uh,
I don't want to butcher it,
but I can certainly also,
I have it in front of me so I can pull it up if need be.
But can you explain for people what motivational interviewing is and maybe give
an example?
Yeah.
So this is actually a,
it's a,
it's a therapeutic technique,
uh,
that actually I think has wider applications.
And I heard about it from a fellow named Mike Pent.
Alondra is that at the Yale School of medicine who used it in,
in,
uh,
I think,
addiction addiction treatment.
And it's basically like this.
So let's say that,
um,
let's say that you have,
uh,
let me think of a good example here of something that somebody typically isn't
that keen to do.
Um,
uh,
lucky.
Let's let,
let,
let's,
let's go to Algebra.
Let's say you have somebody,
let's say you're your parenting,
you have a kid who's in eighth grade and I'm a is,
uh,
has an Algebra test and doesn't want to study for the Algebra test is an intuit,
doesn't want to do it.
And so,
you know,
typical reaction from parents,
from anybody in authority figures like what the Hell is wrong?
You know,
you know,
start thing.
Just sort of demanding,
start demanding compliance and motivational interviewing is almost the reverse
of that.
So it basically,
so let's say you have a kid named Bob,
you could say,
you know,
um,
uh,
hey Bob,
I see you're not studying for your Algebra test.
Um,
let me ask you a question.
You know,
I see you have an Algebra test tomorrow on this.
On a scale of one to 10,
how ready are you to study for your Algebra test?
How ready you are to start studying for your Algebra test?
All right,
how much do you want to start setting for your Algebra test?
And Bob is totally unmotivated by Bob.
Might say,
I'm a three,
uh,
three out of 10.
Now again,
our reaction,
his bosses as parents,
as people in figures of authority is basically is to say,
what do you mean you're a three?
You should be not,
you know,
but instead you're more chill than that.
And you say,
okay,
you're a three,
uh,
why did you pick a lower number?
And that that always wakes people out.
So he says,
I'm a three out of 10 in terms of my desire to do this thing.
And you say,
instead of saying,
Yo,
oh my God,
you should be a nine.
What are you crazy?
You Lazy Ass.
You say,
Oh,
why didn't you pick a lower number?
And what's interesting about that is that is what it does to Bob is that Bob has
to now say why he's not a too.
And so he begins saying things like,
well,
you know,
if I don't study for this test,
I'm,
I'm probably going to bomb the next test.
If I don't master this material,
it's going to be harder to go into later on.
If I don't do well on this test.
You might have so may.
And so what happens is,
is that Bob begins articulating his own autonomous,
intrinsically motivated reasons for doing something.
And that's the key and what we know from a mountain of,
of social science research is that when people have their own reasons for doing
something,
they're more likely to endorse the behavior,
the more likely to carry it out.
And so this becomes a way to serve as Bob's own motivation for it,
um,
through questions rather than through rather than through dictates.
And it can be a very,
very powerful technique.
You can also turn it inward.
Um,
you know,
you say,
well,
how,
how ready are you,
Dan,
to finish this chapter of God?
You know,
I'm like a three.
Then you say,
well,
Dan,
why aren't,
why aren't you a to uh,
you know,
and so anything you can do to help people surface their own reasons for doing
something makes them more likely to commit to the behavior,
more likely to follow through on their behavior
that lasts.
Extension is really important.
I,
I had been prepping this and reading the background,
some of it,
and it didn't even occur to me that you could apply it to yourself and use it
for journaling or something like that to uncover or maybe a rediscover the
motivation that drove you to start it in the first place,
even though you lost sight of it or a petered out or whatever the hell it might
be.
Yeah.
I mean,
you could use it for going to you.
You use it,
you could use it for you.
You could use it for going to the,
um,
you know,
going to the gym or going to,
going to work out.
Like how,
like,
how ready are you,
how,
you know,
how excited are you about how motivated are you to work out right now?
I'm a two.
All right.
Well,
I said to myself,
well,
why aren't you a one?
Well,
you know,
I know that probably I'll feel better if I work out,
write on it if I don't work out.
I know that actually,
um,
if I don't do this aerobic exercise today,
I probably gonna,
you know,
might not have a chance to do it tomorrow,
which means I'm going to feel like crap.
Um,
and so you can,
you can turn it on yourself as well.
It's all about those surfacing,
you know,
one of the things that we've done and turned in management and parenting and all
in all other realms of life is that we have over,
we've overdosed on control.
And control is not an effective way to motivate people for important things.
Um,
because human beings only have two responses to control.
They comply or they defy.
And that's a history of humankind is basically human beings either complying or
defined with control.
Uh,
and so we get,
we need to abandoned control as motivator and look
for ways for people to summon their own autonomous motivation for doing things.
So we talked at the very top of this interview about Johnny Bunko and how uh,
you were ahead of the voters in a sense.
It didn't quite catch,
you might've been a bit early with the Monga format.
In contrast,
a whole new mind seems to really have resonated strongly and it did catch.
So I'd love to try to deconstruct why that was the case.
And as one example,
it's appealed so much to overwinter that she gifted,
I want to say 4,500 copies to the Stanford graduating class of 2008 when she did
her commencement speech there.
Why do you think that is?
And the subtitle I should just mention,
so holding mind,
subtitle,
why right brainers will rule the future.
Why did this one take?
Yeah,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's hard to say.
I think the reason that it took,
uh,
is that it was,
um,
fairly original idea,
uh,
conveyed in a way that was easy to understand and also had the advantage of
probably being more right than wrong.
Um,
so,
uh,
so the idea in that book is the following that I,
that I was arguing then,
I still believe it today that the structure of our brain offers a metaphor for
describing the future of work.
And,
um,
you know,
all your listeners know there's been a lot of stuff written about left brain and
right brain over the years.
Most of it's just total garbage.
But one of the,
um,
one of,
uh,
what we know about our brains is that they're actually somewhat efficient and
then over time they've,
they divided up tasks to the left hemisphere specializes in one set of tasks,
tasks that are logical,
linear,
sequential,
analytical.
The right hemisphere specializes in a different set of tasks,
tasks that are about understanding context,
about synthesis,
um,
and about,
simultaneous processing.
And so,
um,
that division of Labor,
uh,
in the brain I think offers a very powerful metaphor for understanding what,
what's,
what,
what I thought was going on in the world of work and it continues to go on to
the world of work.
But actually to make sure I got the underlying lung science right in a tearing a
page from the Tim Ferriss playbook,
I actually went to the national institutes of Health to get my own brain
scanned,
see my own brain and action,
which ended up being profoundly disappointing experience.
But that's another story for another day.
Um,
and so,
um,
basically the idea here is this,
that the abilities that used to be the most valuable than the economy
characteristic.
It's a metaphor characteristic of the left hemisphere,
logical,
linear,
sequential,
analytical spreadsheet,
SAP abilities.
Those abilities are still necessary,
but there are no longer sufficient and its abilities,
more characteristic of the right hemisphere of the brain artistry,
empathy,
inventiveness,
big picture thinking.
Those abilities are now the first among equals.
And the reason for that is that is a very hardheaded reason that those kinds of
abilities are easy to outsource,
easy to automate.
And the,
the,
the left hand left them.
It's variability.
Sorry.
The left time is for abilities.
The sat spreadsheet abilities are easy to outsource,
easy to automate,
and less valuable in iterating something new,
uh,
in dealing with the demands for new that comes from an abundant world.
And so,
um,
and so I actually,
maybe another reason that took is that I basically came to a soft hard and
conclusion in a hardheaded way.
There was a very clear economic argument for that.
You know,
the three A's,
Asia automation,
abundance,
we ducted left brain work can be done cheaper overseas.
The other AI automation,
it can be done faster by computers and now smart machines.
And then finally abundance that our material needs have been satisfied and
oversight of that.
There's a premium now in coming up with something utterly new and giving the
world something it didn't know it was missing a,
which is a very much of an artistic ability.
And so,
um,
that's the argument in that book and it's an argument I think that people
resonated too cause they were seeing inklings in their own life and they needed
a way to describe it,
categorize it,
put words on it.
Well,
it seems like history is proven.
Your prediction or description very accurate at this point for sure.
And it also would,
uh,
also occurs to me that this is,
this is another place,
uh,
Monga aside where you and Kevin Kelly,
the founding editor of wired magazine,
very much on the same page.
Uh,
you mentioned something in passing though that I can't let go because I have to
hear the separate story.
Why was your brain scan disappointing?
Oh,
because,
um,
it,
you know,
I looked at my brain,
I was thinking my brain would be special.
Some kind of,
it looked like every other brand.
I'd say like I couldn't pick my own brain out of a lineup.
Um,
so that,
that's what it was.
I mean,
it's sort of,
I shouldn't say disappointing.
It's,
it's humbling,
you know,
like the idea that here's the,
here's my,
I got this brain in my head.
All right.
And,
uh,
leaving aside the,
the thorny issue of where does the brain end in the mind begin or vice versa?
Um,
my brain is,
uh,
is,
is largely responsible for who I am.
And yet when I see a picture of it,
it's completely unremarkable and looks like every other brain that's being
scanned that day.
There's something kind of weird and humbling about that.
Disappointing too.
I don't know.
I was expecting my brain would be cooler or something
mean like
looking back at all of your books,
what do you find any commonalities or patterns?
And I mean,
we can also forage all sorts of spurious correlations.
But looking at the books that seem to have struck a nerve and those that for
whatever reason,
didn't perform up to your hopes.
Yeah.
Um,
I,
you know,
I don't know.
I mean,
I think that,
I think that when it comes to actual performance of things,
um,
you know,
like how well the book does,
that's something that's not fully,
I mean,
you know,
this,
I mean,
that's not something that's fully in our control.
And,
and I'm,
and I'm actually,
I'm actually more or less okay on that.
I mean,
it's,
it's disappointing when someone doesn't do as well as you want.
But to me,
my criteria,
my criteria is did I write the best book I possibly can.
Right.
And then once you put it out there,
there's so many other variables.
You just don't know whether it's going to take or whether it's not going to,
whether it's not going to take.
Um,
so I mean,
I wrote a book,
you know,
my first very first book was a book called free agent nation.
Uh,
that was not a monumental,
that did.
Okay.
But it was not a monumental hit.
It should have been because I think I was right.
Um,
um,
but for whatever reason,
I think it came out like I think I think just came out at the raw,
I think it came out at the wrong time.
It should've come out slightly earlier.
Um,
and so,
so on that,
so,
so to me that the,
you know,
um,
how well a book done that's,
there's so much randomness in that.
I'm not,
I try not to lose any sleep over it.
Um,
in terms of actual,
you know,
is there a through line among all the books?
I,
that's an interesting question and I can say from the creation point of view,
there's absolutely not a through line.
There was no intentional through line throughout,
through these kinds of,
through these kinds of books.
It's not as if I have mapped out somewhere on a whiteboard here in pink ink
world headquarters and Washington see this like grand scheme to create the pink
oof in a certain fashion,
in a certain timetable with certain things covered like that far from it.
I just go from one thing to another.
I just like figuring out what I'm going to do next.
And as you know,
Tim,
I mean writing a book is so difficult.
It's so hard.
It's so time consuming that if you're not in love with the idea,
if you don't love working on it,
you're going to,
it's going to be miserable for you.
So,
so I just pick the next topic based on what I'm really interested in and what of
what I want to spend a couple of years,
you know,
a few years working on.
Um,
so I think it's possible that people can detect a through line that readers
could detect the through line.
Maybe they're seeing something that I'm not,
but if there's a through line,
it's visible only retrospectively.
It's not something that was intentional.
What was speaking of difficulty and writing process,
what if there is a,
if you had to pick one,
what has been the most difficult book for you to write and why?
I think it was this,
I think it was the last one,
the last of the last book that I wrote.
Believe it or not,
you would think it would get easier over time,
but it didn't.
Um,
so this last book,
when about the science of Tommy,
that was the most difficult book to write.
Um,
partly because I went to,
I went into that book,
um,
with,
so I went to,
I started writing a whole new mind,
having done the research.
They've done some research and saying,
Hey,
I think there's something going on here.
Like I think we're moving to this world,
you know,
and sort of,
I had a theory of the case with drive.
I had a book about motivation.
I looked at a lot of the research in motivation.
I said,
Whoa,
wait a second.
People are missing like a huge story here with when,
um,
I went in totally with questions rather than with any kind of theory of the
case.
I basically said,
hey,
I'm making all kinds of timing decisions in my own life.
I'm making them in a totally half ass way.
I like to make them in a better way.
Could somebody please give me some guidance?
And I started looking around for guidance and it didn't exist.
And then I started looking at the research and I realized that across all of
these domains of research,
literally dozens and dozens you from,
from the hard sciences and molecular biology to endocrinology to the social
sciences of economics and social psychology,
uh,
too many,
many domains.
These scholars are asking very,
very similar questions.
What's the effect of time of day on what we do and how we do it?
How do beginnings affect us,
how to mid points affect the side of endings affect us.
And so I went in saying,
wow,
how do I make better timing decisions myself?
But it didn't have a theory of the case.
And so the volume of research for this one was so monumental.
There are so many studies out there and there were so many different in so many
different fields and fields like molecular biology is not a subject that is at
my fingertips.
All right?
I had a,
I spent so much time,
I mean it basically would read those papers.
I would read them through and I would write down all the words that he didn't
know the meaning of.
And then I would look up those words and then I would read it again and I would
read it a third time.
And so very painstaking.
Um,
and then also because they didn't have a theory of the case,
I just had questions rather than even kind of skeleton or a shape of what I
wanted to write.
Um,
I had to figure that out.
So I probably did,
I don't know,
17,
18 different outlines,
um,
of,
of that,
of that book.
So that was that what,
you know,
you would think it would get easier,
but it actually got hard.
It would actually got harder.
Teen outlines.
What to what,
to what,
what would such an outline look like?
How long is it,
what's the format?
And when I say an outline,
it's relative,
relatively short,
just like one or two pages.
Nothing,
nothing too comprehensive.
I guess outline is outline is,
is,
um,
outline is,
well,
it's partly the right word because I'm a,
I'm a firm believer when it comes to speeches and when it comes to books,
I'm a firm believer in structure and shape.
Um,
I think that those are what makes some things work.
I think it's stupid television shows.
I think it's true for podcasts.
Um,
I think that structure,
that structure and shape are very important.
All right.
Um,
no.
So here's the thing,
Tim.
I think your podcast,
they don't necessarily have a structure,
but they have a shape.
There's no question they have a shape.
All right?
And so it's a,
you know,
it's just,
it's a difference between,
you know,
we can have,
you can have sculptures,
beautiful sculptures that have right angles and you can have other beautiful
sculptures like a Henry Moore sculpture that has no right angles at all,
but it has a distinct and and identifiable shape.
Right?
So,
so,
um,
but I'm a big believer in,
in,
in structure and shape.
And,
um,
so what I'm doing there is that,
that's basically just my search for how do you organize the ideas and what's the
shape or the structure of the final product going to be.
Because once I see the shape,
I've,
I can do a lot better work.
But for this other book,
you know,
it's like,
like I'm reading through 700 studies on all this kinds of stuff,
and I'm like,
good God,
how do I even make sense of this?
What do I put where I started thinking about organizing it?
Do I organize this book about timing?
Do I organize it basically the way that we organize time?
So do I write about,
you know,
the hour,
the day,
the week,
the month,
the year,
the lifetime,
and that's a really bad way to do it.
But I ended up why?
Why is that bad?
How did you decide that was a bad approach?
Because,
um,
for a couple of reasons.
Number one,
the material didn't organize itself cleanly in that way.
Now on number two,
uh,
that's,
that struck me more as a,
uh,
like a handbook,
like a farmer's Almanac rather than a,
an intelligent book of science journalism with takeaways.
Um,
and more important.
That's not a book I would want to read.
And you know,
and so,
so I,
so I abandoned that,
but I did it.
But did I really abandon it because I actually ended up writing a whole chapter
in this book about the day.
So I ended up cleaving off some of that and,
and keeping it for anything,
keeping it for,
for other things.
And so,
um,
so it took me a long time too.
It took me a long time to find the shape.
And the way I find the shape is I basically write it down on either what I call
big ass stickies is giant post it notes or,
um,
or,
or on a whiteboard that I have in my office.
But I went through many,
many,
many iterations and on that I have a somewhat social view of,
of that.
And that what I'll do is I'll,
I'll run it past people to see what they think,
um,
and say,
hey,
what do you think?
If I organize the book that way,
does that make any sense?
Or,
um,
or what about that doesn't make sense?
Or what am I missing here?
What's the weak spot there?
Uh,
but it took me a long time too.
It took me a long time to find the shape of a of this book.
That coupled with the fact that the,
the amount of research was so massive.
It was,
it was actually,
it was actually the hardest book I've had to write while you're doing the
research as you're writing the book,
right.
In effect,
it sounds like,
because you're coming into it with questions,
but then you're having to digest all of the information that might lead or might
not lead to answers while you're writing it.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
Very,
very hard.
So,
and that's hard to the,
right.
Exactly.
You're so right about that.
That's hard to do two and a lot of people,
I mean,
you know,
as a writer it's,
it's,
it's messier than that.
There's this notion that I'm going to do my research and then when my research
is done,
I'm going to do my writing.
All right.
And so it never works that way.
But when you have more questions than you have when you don't know the shape yet
and you have still have a lot of questions,
what happens is I'm going to do the research.
Now I'm going to try to write down something about it.
Crap.
You know what?
Now that I ride it,
I realize I'm missing a whole thing here and I've got to do more research.
So let me go back and do that.
So it's less of this kind of,
you know,
um,
happy March from,
you know,
uh,
happy jumped from here is I'm going to go from this lily pad to that lily pad
and happily jumped from each one to another like a lighted frog.
There's a lot of task switching.
That's exactly why the four hour chef for me,
it was also by far the most difficult book among other reasons to write is that
I came into it intending to try all of these experiments,
ask all these questions and write the book somewhat chronologically as I'm
getting answers.
And,
uh,
that was a very punishing way to approach things.
But t two to look at the content.
So going past the structure and looking at the,
the content,
the findings of when,
uh,
I was looking at an NPR interview that you did and teasing out some potential
ways that I could apply the content from this book into my own life.
And I'm going to read a quote.
You can feel free to correct it,
but this is,
this is what I have is as one very clear example and I'd love to basically I'm
going to ask you what types of decisions have changed for you or easy ways that
people can think about making changes related to timing.
So here's one then I'm going to,
I'm going to truncate it a little bit,
but quote in a lot of this research and big data,
you see systematically poor performance in health care settings.
In the afternoon example,
the incidence of handwashing inside of hospitals dramatically drops in the
afternoon.
And that seems like a bad thing to me.
My voice,
not yours.
You look at colonoscopies endoscopists find half as many polyps and
colonoscopies in afternoon exams versus morning exams.
Even with the same population,
doctors are more likely to prescribe unnecessary antibiotics.
And the afternoon compared to the morning.
And this seems this is very,
very actionable,
right?
If we are to trust the data,
if the patterns,
if the correlations hold,
then you are certainly better off.
It would seem,
uh,
if you're,
if you want to Miss [inaudible],
uh,
I'm not sure that was English risk mitigate.
I think I swapped the first two letters that has a fancy psychological term.
It's called a,
it's called an linguists.
They got a tip of this lung.
Exactly.
Uh,
and you,
you might come back to your undergrad and linguistics,
but,
uh,
what,
what are,
what are other examples related to the,
when the timing that people can,
might be able to implement?
Oh my gosh,
there's so much stuff.
I mean,
the good news about that is that when I did finally a wrestle the research to
the ground and figure out how to structure it,
um,
it yielded many great,
great takeaways for readers.
So,
so,
so take,
take a step back.
What we know from a mountain of research took me a while to figure this out,
was um,
that we tend to move through the day in three stages,
a peak to trough a recovery peak trough of recovery.
Um,
now most of us move through the day in that order.
people who are night owls,
people who haven't even in chronotype,
they move through the day in the reverse order recovery trough peak.
But what we know is that,
um,
we,
we know a few things about human performance over the course of a day.
The most important thing,
and this is a,
this,
I wish somebody had told me this before I was 50 rather than once I was 50.
All right.
Is that our cognitive abilities do not remain the same throughout the day.
Our cognitive abilities change during the day and they can change in some
dramatic ways and they can change it per day.
They change in predictable ways.
But how we performed depends on what we're doing.
All right?
So what we know about the peak,
which again for most of us is the morning for night owls.
It's later in the day.
What we know about the peak is that the peak is when we are most vigilant.
And what does vigilance made?
Vigilance means we're able to bat away distractions.
Um,
and so when we're vigilant and combat away distractions,
that makes it the best time for analytic work work that requires heads down,
focus,
writing a report,
analyzing data,
that kind of work.
Um,
there's no piles of research.
Tell us that we should be doing our analytic work during the peak,
the trough,
that's the early afternoon and early to mid afternoon.
As you mentioned from the data on on healthcare,
a lot of bad stuff happened then.
I mean,
you have a standardized test scores for students go down in the afternoon.
You have,
um,
if you look at auto accidents,
once you control for cars on the road,
uh,
obviously is to be more accidents when the more cars on the road.
But once you control for that,
the most dangerous time to drive as four to 6:00 AM the second most dangerous
time is two to 4:00 PM.
During that midday trough.
Um,
we should be doing more of our,
uh,
administrative work.
We should be answering our routine emails.
We should,
I mean you,
you,
you talk,
you've talked in the past him about batching.
We should be batching our routine emails and answering them during the trough.
We should be filling out our TPS report.
We should be filling out our expense report,
whatever,
that kind of stuff that we have to do during the course of a day that doesn't
require a lot of major cognitive power.
Now,
the recovery period,
again,
because this peak trough recovery is a pattern of mood that also is a pattern of
performance.
The recovery period is actually really,
really interesting.
During the recovery period,
we have elevated mood.
Our mood is better than during the trough,
but we're less vigilant then during the peak.
And so it's really important to think about that Combo platter here.
That is you have higher mood but less vigilance that makes it a good time for
things like brainstorming for first things like insight work where
if you're too locked down and focus,
you're not going to be that creative.
And so that that degree of looseness coupled with the elevated mood makes that
recovery stage better for,
um,
uh,
what are called insight problems,
brainstorming things that require iteration.
And so what we see is that if you,
if we recognize that our cognitive abilities don't stay the same over the course
of a day,
that they change in predictable ways.
And then what we do that when we do something depends on what we're doing,
we should be moving our analytic work to the peak,
our administrative work to the trough and our insight and creative work to the
recovery.
And it's that simple.
And what the research tells us also is this,
I mean is that time of day explains about 20% of the variance in how people
perform on cognitive tasks.
So if you think about that,
that's a big deal.
Like we can explain the very,
like if Fred,
you know,
if we have two people,
Maria and Sally and they perform differently on cognitive tasks,
how do we explain that?
All right.
We say,
how do we explain that variance in how people before you know,
Maria,
Sally,
and,
and you know,
18,000 other people perform on cognitive tasks.
We say,
Oh,
some people are smarter than other people.
Some people are more conscientious than other people.
Some people have more social advantage and other people.
But what the research is telling us,
a 20% of that variance is time of day.
Um,
and so and so.
So what we should be doing is,
and what we're not doing is we should be making our when decisions in a
strategic way rather than in the lazy hap hazard way with which we tend to make
our wind decisions.
And so,
and you see this most glaringly,
and this is my rant of the,
of the of the year,
is you see this most glaringly with meetings in organizations when we scheduled
meetings and organizations,
the only criteria we use is availability.
That's it.
Who's available.
We don't say what kind of meeting is this?
This is a meeting where people have to be analytical.
What kind of meeting is this?
Is this about travel voucher policies?
What kind of meeting is,
is,
are we brainstorming?
Who's going to be there?
Are they going to be morning people,
are they going to be intermediate people that can be evening people.
We don't even ask those questions.
We just say who's available and it's,
it's causing,
um,
it's,
it's one of the easiest things organizationally to fix and it's something that
at the unit of one,
individuals can be a lot more systematic and intentional about moving the right
work into the right time slots.
What,
what time of day do you generally wake up personally?
Um,
I,
I wake up a little after seven.
And what does,
what does the first two hours of your day look like?
Do you,
do you have particular,
any particular routines?
Can you walk us through what that,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't have the detailed routines that,
um,
that you have that you have written about,
that you actually have experimented with and,
uh,
you know,
things like,
like a journaling and meditation or
anything like that.
Um,
here's what I do.
I wake up,
all right.
I,
I take a shower,
I shower,
helps me wake up.
So I take a shower,
um,
I go downstairs and I feel better if I see a member of my family.
So whoever happens to be awake,
I mean my,
I have two kids in college now,
so I don't see them,
but I have another kid who still are still around.
So I see him,
uh,
I see my wife and I like to have some protein for breakfast.
Uh,
if that's a ritual and caffeine,
protein and caffeine are my,
is my preferred breakfast.
What's your goto protein?
A,
you know what,
I,
I'm a,
I probably eat more hard boiled eggs and almost any other person in America.
I am keeping the hard boiled egg industry in business.
I think I'm single handedly responsible for the advent of hardboiled eggs for
sale and individually wrapped packages in airports.
I really think so because once they,
once they introduced that,
I bought them all and they go,
oh my God,
there's such demand for these hard boiled eggs.
Um,
so,
um,
I was just as actually to by what I eat.
So many eggs is ridiculous.
So,
um,
so I don't have a cholesterol problem fortunately.
Um,
so,
um,
uh,
hardboiled eggs or um,
or pour peanut butter.
And then,
um,
what I do is when I'm in my writing day,
and this is actually something I did better having read this book,
when,
when I'm on writing days,
um,
I will go to my office,
which again is behind my house and I will not bring my phone with me.
Uh,
I will not turn on my email and I will give myself a quota.
And that quota is usually is a word count.
So call it 700 words.
I'm a fairly slow writer.
So you've got these people out there.
I write 3000 words a day and it's like,
I don't think I've ever done that.
Um,
um,
and so very,
very slow.
I'm proud of,
I may be slower than you are even.
Yeah.
Well,
here's the,
I'm slowing basically,
I'm basically slow and every,
um,
in every domain of my life I'm like just such a,
as I'm a slow runner,
I'm a slow reader.
I'm a slow writer.
I like,
I really heavily scrutinize my 23 and me report to see if I had some kind of
like tortoise gene in me somewhere that somehow like one of my ancestors in
Latvia,
some home made mated with a tortoise at some point.
Um,
and so,
um,
so,
but what I will do though is I will come in and get myself that quota and I
won't do anything until I hit that number.
Um,
and then,
then I'm free to do other kinds of things.
Um,
and then what I'll do is I always,
you know,
I'll have lunch and then I will,
um,
I like to do,
I have done a good job,
especially after this,
this book changed the way that I organize my day because I do my analytic work
better in the morning.
So this book,
this book impelled me to clear out my mornings to do that analytic work,
which for me is writing.
I stuffed the administrative stuff often to the,
um,
uh,
to the,
to the mid day and then bashed emails and that kind of garbage.
And then I like to do interviews.
Um,
especially when I'm interviewing,
like for booking interviews,
I like to do those later in the day because I'm a little bit more,
um,
I liked,
I liked the interviews to be a little bit more freewheeling.
I'm not doing,
I'm not an investigative reporter,
I'm not conducting a deposition.
I just,
you know,
want to hear people's stories and what they think about stuff.
And so
Gail law and policy review volume and number two,
that's nine days.
No,
no,
no.
And so I'm not,
I'm not,
you know,
so I want that to be a little bit more iterative.
And then I,
and then I actually ended up exercising later.
I ended up lecture realizing later in the day and in the early evening because I
find that that works best for me.
You said on a writing day when you were on book downline,
how many,
what does your week weekly structure tend to look like?
Do you do,
is everyday a writing day
writing a book?
Yeah,
cause I'm a,
I'm a,
I'm also,
I'm also a momentum player,
so,
um,
so for me,
writing every day is hugely important.
Um,
when I'm,
when I'm working on a,
when I'm working on a book or working on a blog article.
So I tried to do that.
I tried to do that every single day,
like,
like seven days a week.
And do you have,
do you have set periods of time between books?
Do you decide in advance?
I'm going to take x period of time until I investigate another book?
What is,
what is your match macro planning look like?
Macro planning.
Boy,
my macro planning is neither macro Norco
land.
Um,
I think that needs to be on a motivational calendar somewhere.
Like,
um,
I don't know.
It's uh,
uh,
how to put it,
put it another way.
It's that question sucks,
which it might cause it's also making a bunch of assumptions.
How do you decide when to take on new projects or new books,
if that's a better question.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So I,
I sort of go into,
I sort of go in cycles.
So I'm actually heading to that cycle right now.
So I spent a lot of time writing this book and try to make it as good as good a
book as I can in terms of actually spreading the word about it.
I tried to do that with,
you know,
give the Cliche,
not leaving anything on the sidelines and doing everything I possibly can,
being everywhere,
being strategic about it,
all,
trying new stuff,
try and cool stuff.
Uh,
trying to get some momentum behind that behind the book.
And then,
you know,
when that,
and when that sort of white hot center dissipates,
um,
and the book we hope has some momentum of its own,
uh,
then I'll go back and figure out the next project,
whatever that project might be.
And the way I do that is,
I know this will shock you,
Tim,
and they slow,
laborious way.
Uh,
um,
but what I do is,
is I,
um,
I have a,
I'm a sort of,
I use,
I'll give you my mechanisms here.
So I use the blue or not.
I use a lot of paper folders and I have a labeler.
Um,
I use paper folders and a labeler to label my folders.
Uh,
cause I,
I was like a getting things done guy before getting things done.
It was cool.
Um,
the,
uh,
I met,
I met David Island like in 1997.
Um,
and
you know,
I bought a labeler like shortly after that I was going to ask if he's,
if he's sending you your customer,
you know,
5% royalties for your,
uh,
the,
the brainpower,
you're like the guy who invented rollerblades or the Gal,
you know,
40 years before they became cool.
Yeah,
no,
no.
I,
I'm a,
I'm a GTB Devo Tay.
I'm not,
I'm not hardcore.
I'm not like,
you know,
Orthodox,
but I'm not,
I'm not performing,
I'm not reform either.
I'm sort of like in the middle.
And so,
um,
so,
uh,
so anyway,
I have these paper files with labels.
And so when I read stuff or make notes to myself,
I throw stuff in those,
those files.
I use Evernote and I,
you also use Dropbox.
Um,
and I just throw ideas in there.
And then what I do is every six months or so,
I go through those ideas,
uh,
of like,
hey,
this would be a cool shot television show to do.
Hey,
this would be a cool article or write,
hey,
this would be a cool book to write.
And as I look at those ideas,
maybe revisiting them every six months or so,
I realized that most of them are just God awful ideas.
Um,
one of my beliefs about the human brain is that where creativity is that in
order to have good ideas,
you have to have a lot of ideas.
Um,
and so I have a lot of bad ideas,
which I think is the only way for me to surface any decent ideas.
So I'll revisit those ideas and then when it comes,
um,
and I'll,
I'll,
I'll call.
And what often happens when I call is that a few ideas end up just staying there
over and over again,
every six months cycle.
And then when I get to this point now,
I will go back to all of those files and look more carefully and say,
Hey,
I sort of have in my mind's eye right now,
three possible projects.
And,
and so I'll then I'll more heavily vet those projects,
read a lot more,
talk to people,
bounce them,
bounce ideas off of people.
And,
um,
and I like bouncing ideas off of people about which more in a moment.
And,
um,
and then when it comes time to write a book,
I will actually write a book proposal.
Um,
even if I have the deal already done.
So like I have a two book deal,
I have to,
I have to write another book.
Um,
but I'll still write a proposal for this next book,
maybe 40 page proposal,
uh,
which allows me to figure out is there,
there,
there is this something I really want to work on?
Um,
you know,
uh,
I think,
I think a lot of things sound really good when you're just shooting the breeze.
Um,
it,
they sound less good if you have to say,
can I,
can I explain this?
I can explain this idea,
who's going to buy it,
why it's cool,
why its original,
why no one else is doing it.
Uh,
can I explain that in a coherent written document that's a tougher order.
And so not everything lends itself to that.
And I will bounce ideas off of people.
So I had,
so actually it's funny,
mentioned Kevin at the beginning of the show.
Um,
I had just one idea where I went out and I went to,
I made the pilgrimage to a,
what is it?
What did you call his town?
Pacifica Civica um,
yeah and um,
made the pilgrimage to Kevin's house and said,
I got an idea.
I want to run past you a for a book.
And Kevin was one of the people who said that's not a very good idea.
Fortunately he was not the only one who said that.
And um,
or fortunately,
depending on how you look at it,
actually,
unfortunately you're right.
Fortunately he was,
he was not the only one who said that.
So I abandoned,
I ended,
actually ended up abandoning that idea in part because he was another brick in
the wall of people saying,
no,
no.
Let's pause there for a quick second.
Do you mind sharing?
I don't think Kevin would care at all what c or other people made his arguments
against you pursuing this idea and you can tell us what the idea was,
where you can,
yeah.
Were blurred.
I'm going to be,
I'm going to be skittish about the idea.
Um,
uh,
but let's say it had to do with morality.
All right.
I wanted to write a book dealing with morality.
Um,
and,
and Kevin who is a person of religious faith who,
you know,
is extraordinarily well read and among people who are very well read and very
intelligent,
there are,
I think there were a dearth of people who have strong religious space,
um,
that just an observation.
It's not like a
judgment one way or the other.
And so I thought he would be just an especially good person to run this idea
past.
And,
um,
and,
I guess he and others,
um,
the theory of [inaudible] theory of the case that I had,
he and others had to and stuff and they are not insignificant criticisms.
Tin The first criticism was,
you're wrong,
all right to begin with.
Yes,
you're wrong.
All right.
And the second person,
the second criticism,
it was,
you're right,
but it's not interesting.
So those are two pretty like,
that's,
those are like,
those are significant critiques.
Right?
Um,
so,
um,
so that's,
uh,
so that's how I,
that's,
that's generally it.
That's generally how I do things.
When I came up with this idea for when,
uh,
it was an idea that was kicking around there and one of the,
one of the ways that I knew it was a good idea,
uh,
we're,
we're two things.
Number one is that,
um,
uh,
when I was writing the proposal,
when I,
first of all,
I was looking at the research and I found myself wanting to do more research,
which is always a good sign.
It's like,
holy crap.
Is that true?
Well,
what about poverty?
Bob and I go look at Bobby Ball.
Oh my God,
Bobby deposit.
You know?
And so I find myself wanting to do more research.
Uh,
that was one thing.
And then when I started writing the proposal for that,
it was like,
for me,
it doesn't happen very often,
but there were portions of it that were like butter.
I could just explain it so clearly,
like,
here's what I'm going to try to find out and here's why it matters.
And it was like,
it was like that,
you know,
that,
um,
that's seen in,
in Jerry Maguire where he sort of writes all night,
I'm taking the goldfish minus the goldfish.
Huh.
Uh,
I was,
I was doing handstands against the wall and everything like that.
So,
uh,
and,
and that's some,
that's sometimes that's sometimes a good,
that's sometimes a good sign.
I think it's that lack of,
or overabundance of energy I think is undervalued.
How much the project actually gives you more photo tank.
And I think that the big,
you know,
here's the thing,
I think a lot of writers,
I think a lot of people who come out as journalism and before I started writing
books,
you know,
I post speech writing sort of,
sort of as a,
you know,
even the first time those writing books,
I did a lot of magazine articles,
Leatherneck magazine writing,
long form magazine writing,
which I,
which I like.
And I found a lot of journalists who would write an article,
the article would do well and they would get a book offer and they would do,
they would,
they would not pop but they would not properly vetted,
um,
about whether they want it.
Cause there were a lot of ideas that you maybe want to go out on a few dates
with.
But there are very few ideas that you want to go steady with,
let alone marry and have kids.
And I think that books are basically you're marrying and having kids.
Um,
and that's a very,
very,
very high bar.
There are lot,
there are a lot of great articles that should stay articles and to make all my
very mediocre books.
And uh,
you know,
that'd be a potentially,
I suppose not vice versa.
It's very rare that you go in the opposite direction,
but
oh,
that's,
I it's so,
I mean it's so off I read,
I read,
um,
I I want to say the name of it.
I read one of those,
this sentence for me,
a blurb.
I read one of those,
um,
uh,
this weekend where somebody had an article,
it did really well.
They got a book deal,
they turned it into a book and it's like,
okay,
you know what,
this art,
this thing has so much more impact as an article rather than as a book.
Um,
I want to dig in a little bit on this tickler file that you review every six
months.
Yeah.
Because one of the most frequent questions I am asked is how do you pick
projects?
How do you vet projects?
And you mentioned revisiting every six months with a few mundane questions
within Evernote.
Do you have a specific notebook that is tickler file or something like that?
How do you keep track of all of these ideas?
Um,
I,
um,
I can actually look that up right now.
I could,
I want to do is I categorize them.
Um,
so,
uh,
so I have,
so what I have,
and I have a giant file called misc.
All right.
I'm just like,
sure.
It's okay.
But then I'll go through that and say,
Whoa,
wait a second.
Let me think of an example here.
Um,
wait,
um,
wait a second.
I,
I'm,
wow.
I'm collecting a lot of articles about,
um,
here's the book.
I'm not going to like,
it could be interesting because at one point it's like someone should write a
book about courage.
All right?
Like what about courage?
What do we know about courage?
All right,
I'm not going to do that.
If one of your listeners wants to go out and do it,
God bless you.
I think it could be really interesting.
Um,
so I could go into the missing file and say,
Ooh,
the Miss Notebook,
I guess it's called,
um,
is uh,
what do we know about courage?
Uh,
and well,
good in Miss Notebook.
And I said,
wow,
I got a lot of articles about courage,
what that's going to,
they're going to,
that's going to birth a,
a separate notebook on courage,
uh,
and then it organize it that way.
Um,
so I'll have a,
I'll have notebooks of misc and I'll have notebooks of,
of particular ideas that,
um,
that,
that I have,
um,
that end up being full or because it's like,
Whoa,
this,
this one has stuck around for a little bit longer than others.
And Do,
you mentioned during these reviews you might say,
oh,
here's a cool idea for this,
a cool idea for that.
Oh,
this could be really interesting.
That could be really interesting.
I would imagine even after the second glance and noticing that some of these
ideas or coyote ugly and you're like,
Holy Shit,
how did I think that was a good idea.
Even after removing,
uh,
the,
the flies in the soup,
you still,
you still like that I used to live.
You still have way you could drown under the weight of these kind of cool ideas
that you have.
Many things that could be interesting.
How do you then,
what are the parameters or sought processies questions?
Anything that help you to get down to the three finalists?
Um,
okay,
so,
so what do we,
um,
it would be,
uh,
what,
it's,
it's really like,
what would I want to spend a couple of years on?
And so if I really sort of like,
like maybe courage would be an example of that.
It's like,
I'm sort of interested in that.
Um,
but it'd be like,
I would,
I would rather read a good book about courage,
then write a book about courage.
I'm serious.
Like,
you know what I mean?
10.
It's like,
and so when you,
when you go face to face with that and you start saying,
do I really want to do this?
Then I think your,
your soul at some level tells you,
hey,
this is that you're into this.
You're not,
you're not.
So you're not so into that.
Um,
and so that,
I think that's the,
I think that that's the initial cut.
Um,
but it's also the one reason why I,
so to get to the three finalist is actually really kind of intuitive in a,
in a,
in a way,
and it,
and there's no magic number to three.
It could be for,
you know,
um,
and um,
and,
and so,
but this is one reason why I will write a book proposals,
um,
because it just forces me to,
it forces me to reckon with the idea and actually like make it real.
And,
and there's this principle that I learned in college.
I had a writing course in college,
um,
and I actually ended up giving a commencement speech around this idea.
I'll spare you that for now.
But the idea was the idea was filing,
it was a revelation to me when I was,
whatever,
21 years old.
So I had this,
so it was his writing,
his essay writing course,
sort of higher level essay writing course.
And I had a draft of an essay or something like that.
I went into the professor's name is Charlie yarn off you still?
I went to Northwestern.
He still teaches at Northwestern.
And um,
so Charlie,
um,
gave me some feedback and I said,
I was like all insistent,
okay,
I can fix this.
I can move this part over here.
Maybe I do another piece over here.
Maybe I knew another piece over here.
And he's like,
no,
no Dan,
that's not your problem here.
The problem is that you don't know what you think that that's what this essay
sucks.
This drafted the acid.
You don't know what you don't know what you think.
He didn't say stuck,
but that's why this essay,
that's why this essay,
that's why that says he stinks.
And then he said something to me and I,
and I don't want to,
I don't want it to sound glorified or sound like something that is confected
where a swell of music will come up behind me in this.
But what he said,
he said,
but it's words I've never forgotten.
Truly.
He said,
sometimes you have to write to figure it out.
Sometimes you have to write to figure it out.
And that was a revelation to me because at the time I was in this mode,
very kind of traditional schooling mode where sort of like we were talking about
before you do your research,
then you're right,
you make your outline,
then you write.
And what he was saying to me is that,
you know,
the real writers are,
it's more dynamic than that.
Sometimes you have to write to figure it out.
And that was transformative for me.
And so,
um,
that sort of gave me permission to say,
Oh,
I don't know,
like I can change my mind and midway writing something,
I can start writing without knowing fully exactly what it is I'm going to say.
And to me that's the,
um,
that's,
that's why I write book proposals is that I write to figure it out.
And,
and a lot of times what I figure out is this is not a book or this is not a book
I want to write.
So I had this one moment not met a few years ago where a while ago now,
actually 10 years ago,
even more where my,
my I sent,
it was like winter,
like late second half of December.
And I asked,
I said to my wife and I said,
hey,
why don't you just take our guys,
are kids,
three kids just go see your parents.
Just go for a week,
right?
A or two weeks or something like that,
you know,
go and like I just,
I got to get a book proposal done.
I just,
I'm distracted if like,
if you guys,
when you guys were my family leaves,
it's like I live like an animal,
you know?
Um,
I mean I eat,
I've got like a raccoon that got into the house.
No,
truly,
I mean it is raccoon like,
and that I literally eat out of containers,
you know,
so like my,
my family leaves like eat out of containers,
don't shave and basically work around the clock.
Except for a few ESPN breaks.
That's basically what I do when my family has gone.
And so I will,
um,
so I,
so I started,
so I said,
I'm going to write a proposal for this next book.
And after about seven or eight days,
I called Jessica at her parents' house and I said,
hey,
I got some good news and some bad news.
The good news is that you can come home.
Now the bad news is that I realize this is not a book,
um,
it,
but it was only writing to figure out that that allowed me to do that.
So I actually wrote a,
basically one and a half proposals before writing the wind proposal,
uh,
because I had a couple ideas and I said,
okay,
this is sort of interesting,
but let me write to figure it out.
And what I realized in,
in,
you know,
two very important things.
One,
it's not a book.
Maybe it's an article or two,
it's not a book that I want to write.
Um,
there's,
there he sings behavior aside that I want to follow up on.
Uh,
the first is just to highlight something for people listening.
And that is how liberating it is to think about writing as something you do,
not when you have your ideas ready,
but something you would do to figure out your ideas.
Absolutely.
Because it weighs you.
When did you learn that?
I,
it's been,
I would say reiterated,
it's something that is easy to forget,
particularly if you have or something that you will willfully forget if you have
a perfectionist streak and a pension for procrastination.
So if you want to wait until all your ducks are in a row so you can go to the
debutante ball pristine and blow everybody's socks off,
uh,
it's easy to forget this,
but that sounds like,
uh,
you know,
the cat came back the very next day.
I don't think of the song,
but the,
Kevin Kelly needs to can't his name again.
He is a,
he emphasizes to me,
uh,
he's,
he's such a prolific writer and emphasize this to me,
uh,
a number of years ago.
And,
uh,
I want to say it goes back probably to Mcphee who is also much like you obsessed
with structure and,
uh,
if there's a book,
I think it's called draft number four,
uh,
about his,
it's has some,
some really fascinating explorations of this for those people who really want to
get into the weeds.
He'll also do it graphically.
He'll draw out diagrams of what the structure looks like,
which appeals to me.
But trying to stay on track here,
I would say Kevin is the most,
well you are the most recent person,
but a number of years ago,
Kevin emphasize that to me and probably before that make fee.
So it's,
it's really liberating number one,
to embrace that even if you're not fully convinced it's the case.
And,
uh,
I also want to give a little bit of context for people who may not be familiar
with book proposals.
So book proposals in the world of nonfiction books up.
I suppose I should take a further step back and say in the world of nonfiction,
so if you're,
if in novels and fiction are totally different,
in many cases you need to,
you need to finish that puppy before anyone will tell you if your baby is ugly
or not,
which is,
it has to terrifying.
Uh,
it must be in,
in nonfiction,
you create a book proposal before you write your book and the book proposal and
feel free to interject at any point.
But the book proposal is in effect a business plan and an overview slash
executive summary for your book.
And there's,
there's a lot you find with the best book proposals and the best startup
pitches,
which take the form of a deck,
say a PowerPoint or something like that.
Very often they're,
they're exceptionally similar.
The,
the,
the ingredients that make a good startup pitch and the ingredients and making
good book proposal or very similar.
Uh,
but,
uh,
that that is,
and I'd love to actually know what the structure of your book proposals look
like.
I mean,
I know what ingredients I would potentially include in a book proposal.
What does the table of contents look like for one of your book proposals?
Yeah.
Um,
I'd have to go back and look.
I think they vary a little bit,
but they probably have some core design elements.
Uh,
one of them is,
and it's a question that I want to ask myself,
which is,
um,
uh,
what is this book?
What's it about?
Okay.
Pretty simple,
pretty simple question.
Um,
uh,
why is,
I think the more important question is why does it,
why does it fill a need that hasn't been filled yet?
Which is basically very similar.
I use the same business plan analogy that you do on book proposals,
but it's sort of like a business,
like why,
why is it providing,
uh,
why is it filling a need that hasn't otherwise been met?
Like,
like we're like basically if you draw a map in the marketplace,
um,
what part of the marketplace of ideas is,
does this,
uh,
does this cover that hasn't been covered?
All right.
Is it this,
you know,
uh,
um,
so that,
so it's,
you know,
and I don't even mean it in,
I sometimes will use the high concept.
Um,
I sometimes will use the high concept pitch.
It's x meets Y,
which I actually think is actually a very useful heuristic and figuring out
ideas.
So for instance,
I pitched a whole new mind as um,
um,
uh,
future shock meets seven habits of highly effective people.
Um,
it was,
I thought it was pretty good pitch.
And so
a very common in pitching films also just to,
yeah,
just to highlight,
it's a heuristic and it basically,
to me it says,
if you think about a map of the territory,
if you think about a map of ideas out there,
um,
why does no one over here on this part of the map,
right?
Like,
Oh,
show me,
show me where,
show me where on the map you're idea is.
All right.
And let's make sure that someone hasn't gotten there first.
Uh,
and then tell me why someone hasn't gotten there first.
What are they missing?
Um,
and so when the case of when for instance,
I say,
well,
the reason they're missing,
cause everybody thinks science at timing is an art,
but it's actually a science.
Oh,
okay.
Got It.
That's why no one is there.
Um,
and um,
it's all talk about what's it about,
um,
where does it fit into the marketplace of ideas?
Uh,
why is it original?
And this is also really important.
Who is it for?
All right.
And,
and the big mistake that,
that everybody writing about,
and if there's one takeaway from this conversation for prospective writers out
there,
it's this,
the mistake that writers make,
and I think business people make too,
and they're in their pitches,
is when they say,
who's it for?
Who's the audience?
Who's the customer?
They always want to say everybody.
And it's not,
it's never everybody.
All right.
And,
and what I tried to do it,
I've included a section of who is,
who is not going to buy that book.
Like I will have you have a section on who isn't the customer,
right.
I was not who is not going to buy this book because I think that that's the only
way to think carefully about,
because books are not a mass medium.
And even media products in general are no longer mass,
medium mass media.
They're no longer mass.
And it's like,
who is,
and so I'll have bullets and they're saying,
who is not going to buy this book?
Um,
and um,
um,
and that,
and,
and that helps.
And that helps define the audience too.
And also I try to,
you know,
and that that's all that,
that's really all that it is.
But if,
you know,
uh,
what the book is about,
where it fits into the marketplace of ideas of why it's different from anything
else that,
that came before it and why and who's and who it's for,
I think those components are really essential.
But that fourth component is,
and I say this to writers too,
like I raised to tell me who the book is not for,
tell me who's not going to buy this book.
And people have a hard time saying,
well,
everybody will buy this book.
Somebody pitched to me and idea somebody came to me once with the idea of a book
about,
um,
uh,
s somebody was,
give me asking you advice on it.
It was a book about,
um,
I,
I hope I don't,
I don't,
I think the book might have gotten published.
I don't want to reveal the name.
Uh,
it was a book about the history of Yoga in America.
All right.
The history or remove the history of you.
Yeah,
I think it was a history of yoga and I was like,
oh,
okay,
that's cool.
So I think a lot of people,
um,
who do yoga might be interested in that.
And she said,
well,
I think people who don't do yoga are going to be interested in this.
And I said,
no,
they're not like people who don't do yoga don't care about the history of Yo.
All right,
you can,
there are a lot of their shoe,
a lot of people in America who do yoga.
I like,
that's a pretty good audience right there.
But don't tell the every,
you know what I mean?
And so,
um,
you know,
uh,
so,
so for me it's like,
you know,
for me it's like,
like my books.
Like,
okay,
I know that the,
um,
the,
like this book about the science that this book about the science of timing,
I know that um,
certain people in my neighborhood in northwest Washington DC who read or of a
certain age and read only,
um,
uh,
literary fiction and 700 page biography is a founding fathers.
They're not going to read this book.
They're not going to read it.
They might be my neighbors.
They're not going to read one of my books.
Um,
and so I think that's really,
really important about who is the book not for,
well,
it's also an indicator of focus and logical slash a rational thinking in a
sense,
right?
Because if you're,
for instance,
just to digress for a minute,
but if you're in the world of investing where I spent a long time with early
stage startups,
17 years or so,
if they say everyone is my customer,
there was a very real risk that if you give them x number of dollars,
you give them $1 million that they could be developing Dropbox for say early
tech adopters in the first wave and they,
they need to get from zero to 10,000 users.
And if there is a a a 80% off deal for something like shopping mall circulars or
something that they would jump on that and Piss,
piss away all their money.
And uh,
yeah,
we'd certainly,
I think books,
a lot of books fail and this is true presentations too from too much
miscellaneous information,
not too little a,
if that makes any sense.
Absolutely.
It's a,
it's a matter of,
it's a,
it's,
it's really just a matter of,
it's really just a matter of focus.
And I'm going back to the speech thing.
I mean,
one of the,
one of the pieces of advice to the extent that anybody ever asks me for advice
I'm giving,
I'm giving speeches and whatnot,
is,
um,
you know,
and it sounds a little like a,
it sounds like a Zen Koan ish sort of phrase,
but it basically,
my point is,
uh,
say something important rather than saying important things.
Um,
and like I find a lot of times people say something important rather than say
important things that,
cause I think a lot of times people like that sort of stuff within the skin,
all the things they found out,
all the things that they know and they ended up not saying anything important.
Um,
and so,
you know,
um,
I,
yeah.
So,
um,
uh,
so that's,
that's the reason for doing it.
That's so,
anyway,
you get the idea.
Yeah.
No,
it isn't.
There are so many,
uh,
comparable examples.
Uh,
if,
if for instance,
you look for this,
this vetting of ideas by putting together a
short synopsis of some type.
And there's one example,
for instance,
and I believe this is true,
uh,
I've,
I've certainly heard it and read about it a few times and I know a fair number
of people who work at Amazon,
but they didn't have to confirm.
But I think Ian Mcallister,
who used to at least be a general manager at Amazon,
talked about this is working backwards and for,
for new,
for new initiatives,
the product manager who would be in charge of developing,
say a new product,
has to write an internal press release,
which announces the finished product,
right?
So that,
and that has to focus on effectively exactly what,
what you said.
And I'm quoting here from,
uh,
a medium piece,
but quotes centered around the customer problem,
how current solutions,
internal or external
fail and how the new product will blow away existing solutions.
And,
uh,
it's the same thing.
It's the same thing.
If you can't write that press release,
like how on earth are you going to navigate the decision tree of getting to a
product that finds its feet?
I mean,
it could be very different,
difficult.
Not to say you don't iterate,
but,
uh,
it's,
it's a good idea.
It's a good filter through which you can at least catch the detritus that
shouldn't make it to step two.
Oh Man,
I have to say I am your Hallelujah chorus on that press release technique.
Uh,
I've,
I've literally done that,
uh,
working with,
working,
uh,
I think it's helpful for like nonprofit groups that I'm involved in.
So nonprofit group wants to do a big project,
but they're all over the place.
They don't know exactly what they want to do.
And I literally did this,
I said,
I'll tell you what,
here's what I think the project has.
Let me write a press release from two years from now and they'll send it around.
And it ended up being,
uh,
I got the idea from Amazon too.
It ended up being this,
it ended up being this thing that was really,
really focused.
So the,
the Blahbidy Blah,
uh,
group,
announced today that it was doing Bobby blabity,
blabity blah.
And it's like,
you know,
and then he had a quotes and things in it and it,
and it being this,
this focal point on for the whole organization on what are we actually trying to
accomplish here.
So I'm a,
I'm a I second that emotion there.
Big Time.
And just to return to another thing that you said,
which I'll paraphrase here as if everyone's your customer,
no one's your customer.
Uh,
another filter Yvette or question that I use or have used,
I'm not really in the startup game anymore,
but have used a lot with startups because they'll ask me,
you say a landing page and look at copy and messaging and so on and before I
will review it because I'll,
if,
if with no further information I have to review it based on my pair of eyes and
my perspective and my particular problems that I can try to empathize then put
myself in other people's shoes.
But I have to know whose shoes to put myself in.
And so I'll ask them,
if you could only have a thousand people sign up for this,
who would they be and why?
Like,
describe for me,
and this isn't a politically correct exercise,
like what is gender,
uh,
race,
if that matter is maybe it doesn't,
like where do they live?
What magazines or websites do they read?
Uh,
what is their household income?
Like really get granular about what these people have in common,
right?
Like,
do you want all the readers of people magazine?
Do you want the 2000 people who attend?
Ted?
Do you want something in between?
Like really described that for?
And only once that's been done,
can I actually give feedback on modifying any of the features or copy or
messaging on a particular page,
uh,
sets,
I mean it's,
it's these,
these principles really transferred to a lot of different areas.
Well,
I,
let me ask a a just a handful of additional questions and then maybe we can do
around two sometime.
But the,
we've been talking a lot about the decisions you've made,
the routines that you have.
And although you're very self effacing,
I mean someone could look at your bio and be very intimidated and assume that
you step up to the plate and hit home runs more often than not.
Uh,
could you tell us about
maybe a specific,
if you're open to it,
difficult period that you've gone through or a down period,
challenging period or failure,
it could be any of those things and what you did to get back on your feet or the
decisions you made that helped you then can get back on firm ground if a,
if anything comes to mind.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
There are all kinds of things.
Um,
so I mean,
I hate to keep going back to the,
I hate to keep going back to the law school days,
but um,
but I,
um,
uh,
I did Lee law school after my first year.
Uh,
and I hated it so much that I went to India instead.
And,
um,
I traveled around,
I traveled around India,
which was a incredible life changing experience because I was a young guy,
you know,
whatever old I was like 25,
26 years old.
And you know,
at the time it was,
you know,
it was awhile ago,
so at the time India was even cheaper but much,
much cheaper than it was.
So if you're like,
uh,
a 25 year old dudes traveling on your own with a little tiny little bit of money
in her pocket and you can make it to go very,
very,
very far.
And so,
um,
so at the time I guess I felt like,
because I didn't do very well in my initial foray into law school,
I didn't really like it.
I was pretty miserable.
I felt that had made a terrible decision and I s some level just tried to
escape.
And,
and the way I got back into it was,
um,
essentially saying,
okay,
if I'm going to do this,
then,
um,
I'm going to try to figure out what are the one or two things that I can find
valuable and this experience and just try to power my way through.
And I guess that's all I get.
That's all that I get.
That's all that I,
I guess that's all that I did to do,
to overcome that.
But I felt pretty bad about how I didn't do very well.
I didn't,
I didn't really like it.
I thought I had made it.
Like I thought I had made like a ruinous decision about,
about how my life was going to go and when I sort of kind of woke up and matured
a little bit,
I said,
okay,
some people make like bad things actually happened to people.
And I think going to India was actually helpful in that regard too because like,
okay,
I'm not living in a tar paper shack with filthy water.
Right.
I'm just,
I'm not,
I'm not self actualizing fast enough for a 25 year old middle class person,
that's not a real problem.
Um,
and so I think that sort of putting the problems in perspective and just trying
to find some,
um,
some goodness in what you're doing next.
And also I just like really deriving specific lessons from these kinds of
failures.
And I think that's another part that's important to me is it rather than rather
than simply allow like sort of this hazy notion of what you learned.
I,
again,
I'm a big believer in writing things,
in writing things down.
I'll give you,
I'll give you a better,
I'll give you a better example of that.
Um,
uh,
and this is,
I don't want to call this like a,
a major failure cause it's not that,
that's not that significant.
But,
uh,
so I did a TV show for National Geographic and I worked with,
TV series and I worked with some really great people and we put on a really
fricking great show and it didn't get picked up for a second season.
And,
um,
and so it was disappointing,
but it's not like a massive failure.
It's not like anything real like in life.
But at that time what I did is I said,
you know,
I basically framed it a file and said,
okay,
here's what I learned from this experience.
Things that I learned from this experience.
Like,
one,
I like working with really talented people.
They are people who helped me perform better to um,
I don't like to be involved in projects that I don't have full control,
creative control over three.
Um,
um,
working with people in traditional television can be very perilous because
they're subject to all kinds of pressures that are out of their control.
And so you have this experience where things didn't go the way you want it to,
but if you actually literally right down the lessons,
I think you can get something positive out of it.
And it was the writing down of these lessons,
more of a Cathartic exercise or these,
would you go back and revisit that?
You know what I like?
Like for me,
a lot of times what I will do is,
for me it's sometimes certain writing things down is simply the act of writing
it down is enough to solidify it.
Um,
so I'll do the kind of thing where before a talk or something like that,
I will,
um,
like write an outline.
Like,
like basically I'll,
I'll,
I'll know what I want to do and then I'll take notes and write an outline of the
speech.
And the points I want to hit and then I literally will not look at it like I
sometimes won't even bring it up with me.
I'll forget to bring it up with it because the act of the act of actually
memorializing it is really what gives it,
it's,
this is,
uh,
what,
what I don't want what I'm trying to say in a,
in a,
in a somewhat ham handed way is that like when you,
you want to,
um,
you don't want those kinds of lessons to be hazy too much.
Uh,
you want to actually like what,
like what specific thing that I actually derive from this.
Um,
and I think that's really useful.
There's also a great technique that Tina Seelig has used.
You can see like he was at Stanford has,
has used where she talks about she writes a failure resume,
so she has a resume of all of our failures.
And then with each one what she learned from it.
When would she use something like that?
Um,
I mean she keeps it for herself,
but she would use ongoing working document just like,
yeah,
yeah.
Ongoing working document that basically,
so you can look at it and say,
okay,
what are the,
you know,
boy,
I made a lot of mistakes,
but here's what I learned from them and don't make the same mistake a second
time.
I don't mind making mistakes.
What I don't like is making the same mistake twice
with the,
uh,
two questions on India.
Why India?
And then second,
how did you decide to find the compelling,
I suppose,
benefits of continuing with law school versus changing course?
Um,
let's see.
uh,
you know what I think,
okay,
it's on the second one.
I think it was too risk averse to change course fully.
Um,
I think that the,
I think that would have been too much,
excuse me,
too much of like a narcissistic injury just to like leave all together.
Uh,
I probably would've,
I probably would've felt like an abject failure.
So I don't even think that was in the cards.
Um,
so on,
on the white India,
a couple of reasons I'd always been fascinated by it.
Um,
I knew that,
that I could get around,
um,
that,
that I,
uh,
the previous summer I had been to southern Africa and,
you know,
um,
and it was the first,
I had never been out of the country,
um,
uh,
until I was 23 years old.
Um,
and so the first time I left the country,
I went to southern Africa,
um,
on,
uh,
I,
I got a raise some money to,
to do this,
to do a project there.
And they were,
that was a revelation.
It's like,
holy crap,
this world is a lot bigger than I thought.
And so I wanted to go to someplace that wasn't,
you know,
Europe or someplace that was a little bit different from a little bit more
different from the United States.
Um,
and so in India was a place that always been fascinated by,
it spoke English and it was cheap.
That's,
that's a compelling combination for someone even in law school for a period.
Yeah.
When you're 25 years old or however old I was,
and um,
and you have like a little money in your pocket,
but you can go,
you could go so far on so little money.
It was unbelievable to me,
you know,
especially if you're willing to like sleep over,
like take over night trains rather than pay for a place to stay.
Um,
or you know,
live in these,
you know,
go to sleep in these places where there's just a row of beds on a,
on a balcony and the mosquito nets over each one.
So the,
uh,
I mean,
travel is one of those gifts that keeps on giving in a sense.
Uh,
I would put books in that same category.
Yeah,
I agree.
You've written a lot of books,
you've read even more books,
uh,
besides your own,
and I'll just get a segway into a couple of short questions.
What,
what books?
Are there any books that you've gifted often to other people or repeatedly out
of people?
Oh,
yeah.
Um,
uh,
so,
they're probably books that you're,
uh,
I,
I'm at a might've been books that you've covered in this,
in your show here.
So one of them is bird bird by Anne Lamott.
So one of the greatest things ever.
Um,
I come back to that advice so many different times.
It's,
it's a saying,
even in the pink household,
uh,
were like,
we'll just say like one member of my family say to the other who's struggling.
Okay.
Bird by bird,
bird by bird.
Um,
and so,
um,
I am a huge,
and I stumbled into this book.
I remember I've got,
I remember where I got this next book.
I got it in the airport in San Francisco,
uh,
in,
in the,
uh,
the bookstore in the San Francisco Sfo.
Um,
and for some reason,
uh,
I picked it up because it had this really weird cover,
but one of the first additions of the war of art by Steven Pressfield had this
kind of silvery covered to it.
And I bought that book in the,
I think there's a compass bookstore in Sfo just because,
wow,
that's kind of cool.
It's silver cover.
And it's really short.
And I got it.
And it's like,
oh my God,
I can't believe how good this book is.
Um,
and so I even have a little sign on my desk here that says beat the resistance.
So I've given that book out a lot too.
So press field and Lamont and then,
um,
man,
I have to say Victor Frankl,
man's search for meaning a is up to up to I,
it's less I give it to be,
I,
I've given out out less.
But uh,
that's a,
that's a hugely important book for me.
Yeah,
that's,
that's one of those books I really need to reread.
And I think you've,
you've actually spoken about,
uh,
let,
let me get this right.
I was about to say animal house,
but that is not right.
Animal farm or all that kind of simple form.
Is it?
I out farm is one of the greatest books ever
and,
and how you,
it's a completely different experience as a book at different points in your
life and absolutely.
Right.
And the last time I read man's search for meaning was probably,
I would say seven to 10 years ago.
And a lot of changes in my life in that period of time.
I think that that is worthy of a reread.
Uh,
and have you,
it sounds like you've re-read each of these books also bird by bird,
the war of art man.
Search for meaning yourself.
You've read these more.
Yeah,
I've read it more than one.
Yeah.
And uh,
but I'm not,
I'm not chronic
reread or I'm like,
there are some people who are regularly re there.
There were relatively few books that I have that I have re-read.
Um,
uh,
but,
but those,
those,
uh,
those I absolutely have.
And once I had another experience in college,
I guess the only thing I remember in college are shards of things that
professors said,
like basically one liners.
Uh,
but I had a professor once in college who in an American studies course,
he assigned us to read the adventures of Huckleberry Finn.
So you're at,
you're in college and your professors assigned you to read the adventures of
Huckleberry Finn.
People are like,
oh,
you know,
because like everybody read that book in high school and,
and he said something,
he said the following words,
he says,
I know you've read that book,
but you haven't read that book,
meaning the person you are today.
And,
and that ends up being,
but that ends up being true.
So when I've read,
uh,
I read animal farm at different points in my life,
um,
uh,
and,
and had different view on it.
I read great Gatsby at different points in my life.
Um,
I have seen the play a death of a salesman.
MMM.
Perform,
I don't know,
probably seven times.
And each one feels a little bit different to me.
I had a completely different view of death of a salesman once I became a father
versus before I became a father.
Um,
it can,
I had,
I had a,
another view of death of a salesman,
uh,
before I knew about,
you know,
new know had,
had read about psychopharmacology and mental illness and after I did.
Um,
and so,
you know,
I,
I think that that experience,
I think those kinds of experiences are really fascinating.
Animal Farm.
I was like,
oh,
it's really cool.
It's about the Soviet Union and power corrupts and blah,
blah,
blah.
And,
and I,
and now I read the book,
it's like,
okay,
this book is basically about organizational dysfunction.
This book,
I would cares whether it's supposed to be at the Soviet Union.
This book is about the acne widget corporation and how screwed up human
organizations are like this.
I,
I think that animal farm should be in every organizational behavior class in an
MBA program.
That's another one.
I need to reread.
Not a long book either.
I mean,
I read that in sixth grade or something.
come on,
you'll see it completely.
You'll see it completely differently.
That's a,
that's a great book.
I've written 19 before,
multiple times too.
Also a very timely book.
Uh,
these days
on that front,
I,
I read,
uh,
the Handmaid's tale for the first time.
I have sort of 30 years late to it that I read on.
I love that book.
Um,
I have a whole,
I'm not joking around.
I,
and if you want validation I'll send you a photograph of an eye.
I basically have a stack of books right here that,
that's basically dystopia books that includes Philip Roth,
the plot against America,
um,
and Octavia Butler book.
Um,
Sinclair Lewis.
It can't happen here.
Um,
another Saifai book called a Elliot Elliot Pepper called Cumulus and other one
called Infomart cracy by Monica older.
I have a whole,
um,
I'm basically,
I have a whole pile of dystopian works.
Why is that?
Why do you,
why do you really want to understand?
I want to understand that the current moment more,
more clearly.
So,
well this might be,
just might be an appropriate next question.
It doesn't have to be related to what you just said,
but if you could put a short message on a billboard,
metaphorically speaking,
to get a word,
a quote,
a question out to millions or billions of people,
what might you put on that billboard?
Well,
it's interesting cause I think it is related to um,
what we were just talking about or maybe the fact that you asked it in this
context made me relate it.
Um,
but one of the,
um,
one of the things that I would,
I would write would be assume positive intent that would fit very nicely on a
billboard assume,
assume positive intent.
Because I think,
and I,
and I've changed my view on this,
Tim.
Uh,
I've actually in some ways become,
um,
I've sort of gone the reverse.
Like,
like basically the general view is that people are idealistic when they're young
and cynical when they're older.
And I've actually become less cynical as I've gotten older.
Uh,
and um,
the other thing is basically on,
on politics,
like,
you know,
there's this old line in politics like everybody dies a Republican,
cause like as you get older and you have something to conserve,
you become more conservative.
I found myself going actually the opposite,
the opposite direction as I understand more about the more about the world.
But the point is a point of all that and assume positive intent is that I think
it goes to our politics right now is that a lot of times I don't,
you know,
I just think like your default,
you know this already,
our default settings are so important in any realm of our life.
And I think a lot of times if your default setting is that people have,
everybody you deal with has negative intent that's going to lead you down one
pathway.
There's no question about it.
And,
and I,
and here's the thing,
I don't think that's true.
I really,
my experience as a human being is that some people obviously have negative
intent,
but most people do not.
Most people actually have positive intent.
So my view is that if you assume positive intent on the part of others and let
them disprove that,
that's a better way to go than to assume negative intent and say,
I'm going to assume that you have negative intent timferriss until you prove
that you actually have positive intent.
Um,
I think just doing the reverse during the reverses better,
it's like assume positive intent.
That's it.
I don't,
I'm not Pollyanna here.
I don't think everybody has positive then,
but I think most people do.
And if you just just make that your default setting,
you're going to have better interactions with people.
You're gonna learn,
you're gonna learn a lot more.
The default setting default state as you put it in this case,
creates a completely different experience of reality.
Uh,
it was a little bit whether it's guilty until proven innocent as you look at
everyone in anything around you or innocent till proven guilty.
And I remember you're talking about these one liners,
these shards that,
that stick in the mind.
I remember,
I can't,
I can't recall who said this to me,
but they said if you go out one day,
you walk around and you meet an asshole,
that person is an asshole.
If on the other hand you go out and everyone you meet is an asshole,
you're the asshole.
And it,
if you assume that everyone has negative intent,
you yourself become that which you loath.
Boy,
that's a really good point
and a very good point.
I love that.
Assume positive.
Well,
uh,
how's up?
It's on a billboard.
It does.
I was actually taking that thing very literally.
It was like I literally picturing in my head like what would be,
what could,
what could fit on a,
what could fit on a billboard.
Well,
I think that's,
I think that's a great place to wrap.
Uh,
I mentioned a few things at the top of the show,
Dan,
pink.com at Daniel Pink on Twitter,
Facebook,
Daniel h pink.
Is there anything else that you would like to mention as closing comments and
requests and ask of the audience?
Anything else you would like to say?
No.
I mean we,
you've covered a lot.
We've covered a lot of ground and you know,
if people have listened this far,
God bless him.
I mean,
I can't,
I that's,
I even,
I'm not that in grateful,
uh,
to ask for something more after this kind of indulgence.
Well,
I,
I'm a big fan of your work.
I haven't been for a very long time and I,
including Johnny Bunko,
which I still have to this day.
So you may recall ages ago,
lifetimes ago,
I think it was at south by southwest actually,
which is timely since I now live in Austin,
Texas.
You inscribed,
uh,
you signed a copy of that book for me,
which I still have.
I've carried it with,
I remember where we were sitting.
Yeah,
I do.
So I appreciate it and I still have the book and it's really been nice to
reconnect and catch up a bit.
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah,
it's been fun to,
you know,
obviously it's good
fun to watch,
uh,
all the great things that,
all the great things that you're doing and just how this,
this massive audience that you built in this,
you know,
I've gotten so much,
I have my dog eared.
I,
you know,
it's too bad we're not on video,
but I could show you my dog eared copy of,
um,
tools of titans,
which is a,
would you,
they,
which is a great book title by the way,
is the only book title that came easily and is the oil one.
All the other ones were agonizing,
agonizing,
agonizing sessions of brainstorming and picking one the of the titles among many
that I felt dissatisfied with,
tools of titans for whatever reason,
uh,
thanks to the universe or whatever powers that may be or,
or a reluctant may have happened upon me,
but that,
that is one that just kind of came and I was like,
oh yeah,
no,
that's,
that's the title.
And that was it.
I didn't,
I also didn't realize that you were in Austin.
How did you end up in Austin or why did you end up,
uh,
I,
I have felt a gravitational pull to Austin for a very long time.
I in fact wanted to move here right out of college,
but I didn't get the job at trilogy software that it made it to a final round of
interviews,
which brought me out to Austin,
really fell in love with the town.
Uh,
the,
the baseline of friendliness and warmth here of neighborly feel is higher than
just about any other place I've experienced.
And then instead of getting a job here,
he got a job in the bay area,
which took me to San Jose and mountain view and San Francisco for the better
part of nearly 20 years,
which I loved for that period of time.
But much like with books,
I think that you visit places and your experience of those places changes over
time.
And what,
what attracted me to the bay area I think has,
uh,
has,
has morphed into something else and I have also morphed into someone else.
And it felt good.
It felt like I felt like a good time for me to experiment with a new location.
Also,
I found myself within the very almost inescapable conversation of tech to,
uh,
be just drinking the Koolaid a little too heavily or repeated or believing my
own bullshit.
Maybe not,
not necessarily bullshit,
but getting caught up in a lot of platitudes that are thrown around so often in
silicon valley to have become part of the daily vernacular.
And that scared me quite frankly,
that I was like,
wait a second.
If I look back at the last five to six months,
how many conversations have I had that don't include the following 12 words or
four 12 expressions.
Oh yeah.
It was like,
wow,
I can actually count them on,
on both hands thing.
Interesting.
And uh,
what did you grow up?
I grew up at the very end of Long Island and uh,
was born a townie in the Hamptons,
which is a very odd thing
for anyone.
For anyone who's seen the affair.
I have not,
but I've heard that the affair,
this TV show that is apparently quite popular,
a lot of it takes place in this restaurant called the lobster roll,
which is in Montauk and I used to be a busboy at oh wow.
Nice.
Yeah.
So Long Island is,
is,
is where this,
this,
I do this whole weirdly,
I remember from
four hour work week.
I think that,
okay.
You described yourself as a hellion.
Hell again,
a little hellion,
good memory,
which is a great word.
I was just such a great word.
Yeah.
But I,
but I realized I didn't have any geographic sense of where you,
uh,
where you,
where you grew up.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
I think the use of [inaudible] is actually in the dedication to my parents and
my,
yeah.
Think that's right.
I think that's right.
You know why?
One reason I remember that is that I listened to part,
uh,
I got part of that book on audio book.
Um,
and I remember at the Biggie because you read that book,
I'm almost certain,
yeah,
it was ray porter who
has,
has a voice that is easily
mistaken for my,
my various mannerisms that I've developed now via podcasts.
So that was,
that was ray porter.
He did a great job.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
But I'm pretty sure that I,
but I know it's just a great word.
It is a good word.
It's great.
And,
uh,
I'm going to try to use it in the next 24 hours when I have,
when I come up with a good,
when
I hear a good word I try to use,
I try to drop it in the next 24 hours just because it helps to reinforce it for
me.
Well,
I'm going to try to use surrogation and I'm going to try to eat more horrible
the eggs and the next 24 hours.
Uh,
you're,
you're golden.
It,
your life will change markedly if you start employing the principles surrogation
while eating our build eggs,
everything will,
you're there.
Every,
the sun will come shining up and the sun will,
will,
will burst out from behind the clouds and unit unicorns will scamper across your
front lawn.
Well,
my,
my dog will love that.
And uh,
then this has been,
this has been a lot of fun.
Thank you for having me.
I appreciate it.
It was a lot of really interesting and for everybody listening,
as always,
you can find links to everything and including,
uh,
dance,
social website,
the new book when,
and a much more in the show notes,
which you can find@tim.blog slash,
podcast.
And until next time,
thanks for listening.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend?
And five bullet Friday is a very short email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the,
uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends,
for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour workweek.com that's four hour work,
week.com all spelled out and just drop in your email and you'll get the very
next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by we work.
I love,
we work.
I haven't had an office in many,
many,
many years since 2000 or so when I had my last real job,
I suppose in quotation marks,
but when I moved from San Francisco to Austin not long ago,
I decided to do,
you know what?
I'm tired of working at home.
I'm tired of,
we're going to coffee shops.
So one of the very first things I did was to get a space that we work.
I could not be happier with this change in my life.
We work is a global network of workspaces where companies and people grow
together.
The idea is really so you focus on your business and we work takes care of all
the rest including front desk service,
utilities,
refreshments,
and I also often have been shipped from Amazon and elsewhere to my office that
we weren't,
you're in Austin.
I've been completely blown away by the members only events,
special offers and perhaps the best brew coffee on tap than I've ever had.
It's been amazing.
It's been a real,
real change in my life and improved my quality of life and there are also dog
friendly.
We work locations all over the place.
How Fun is that?
We work caters to everyone from entrepreneurs and freelancers to start ups and
even large enterprises including Ge,
salesforce,
Microsoft,
mastercard,
Samsung,
Spotify,
Pinterest and red bull among many others.
In fact,
more than 10% of fortune 500 companies currently use work and it's a rapidly
growing group.
In other words,
it's not just solo printers and to ground level startups that loose we worked
with,
but everything from that to the big companies who are seeing very huge benefits
as well.
We work believes that creating spaces where people can connect and create
meaning together,
right after all,
if you are someone who's built a business model on the principles and the four
hour workweek or elsewhere,
it can be a lonely road.
Sometimes even though you're digitally connected,
it can feel very,
very isolated.
So in these spaces you could connect with real humans and uh,
all the while you space more efficiently and cost effectively,
which makes you and your business better equipped to face the challenges of
today.
Tomorrow we work now has more than 200 locations,
so you can find great spots all over the world.
So head over to [inaudible] dot co slash Tim that's [inaudible] Dot Cosio
we.co/tim to become a part of the global we were community.
At the very least.
I encourage you to check out pictures of some of the locations around the world.
There are some incredible spots.
So check it out.
[inaudible] dot co slash Tim this episode is brought to you by four sigmatic.
You might remember four sigmatic for their mushroom coffee,
which was created by those clever finished founders.
And when I first mentioned that coffee on this podcast,
the product sold out in less than a week,
it lights you up like a Christmas tree,
which can be really useful.
However,
recently I've been testing the opposite side of the spectrum of new product and
that is their Reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my day to get to sleep.
As you guys may know,
longtime listeners,
at least I struggled with insomnia for decades.
I've a largely fixed that,
but still shutting off my monkey brain has never been easy.
It still isn't easy very often and I found Reishi,
which I've been fascinated by it for a few years now,
has been very,
very effective and calming their old formula.
However,
four sigmatic old formula included Stevia and I like to avoid sweeteners,
all sweeteners for a host of reasons and I then just ping them and asked,
hey guys,
I would love to experiment with this and maybe actually suggested,
but I'd like a version without sweeteners if you'd be open to it,
if too much of a headache,
don't worry.
And they are always game for experimentation.
So they created a special custom version without the Stevie,
without sweeteners.
Now it is part of my nightly routine.
Their ratio elixir comes in single serving packets,
which are perfect for travel and in fact I'm about to leave the country right
now and I have a packet in front of me that's just going to sit in the end of my
carry on bag.
You only need hot water and it mixes very,
very easily.
Here's some recommended copies that they put in the read,
so I'm going to read it and I'll give you my take quote,
a warning for those in the experimental mindset,
Reishi is strong and bitter and parentheses like any great medicine.
So if the bitterness is too much,
I recommend trying it with honey end or nut milk such as almond milk and quote.
So I'm going to say no,
you should suck it up and you should drink the tea because it's not that bitter.
And maybe should take the advice of all Chinese people when they're criticizing
young ins when they say,
well,
I'm sure cool,
which means you're not able to eat bitterness.
Bitter is in many cases and indication of things that help liver detoxification.
It's on,
not saying that's the case here,
but I've tested this ratio lecture on family members,
on friends,
everybody has liked it.
It's a little bit,
or if the,
it's not that hard.
So I would just say suck it up and no,
don't put in honey or milk or any of that shit.
Just drink the goddamn tea.
It's delicious I think.
Right?
If you like poo air,
that kind of stuff,
that type of tea,
you're going to dig it.
So just try it.
Okay.
Back to them by read.
If you'd like to naturally improve your sleep,
both onset and quality,
I think naturally you might just enjoy this ratio lecture without any sweet
nurse.
It has organic,
Reishi extract,
organic fueled,
mid extract,
organic rose hips extract,
organic Tulsi extract.
And that's it.
No fancy stuff,
no artificial watching McCall at anything.
So check it out.
Go to foursigmatic.com forward slash Ferriss and get 20% off this special batch.
I don't know if they're gonna be making much more of this,
uh,
since it was made specifically for you guys to do me a favor and try it out so
that they continue to be open to experimenting with me to create products for
you guys.
Specifically.
Check it out.
Four sigmatic,
that's Fou,
c.com forward slash Ferris,
s and get 20% off the special batch.
And you must use the code Ferris to receive a discount FTR our ISS.
So again,
going to foursigmatic.com forward slash Ferris and then use code Ferris or 20%
off of this rare exclusive,
limited run of Reishi mushroom elixir for nighttime routines with out in enjoy.